Okay.
Good,
good,
good.
All right man.
John Ghoshal.
What's up buddy?
I say right.
Got Y'all.
You got it.
It's not that difficult.
It just looks difficult.
Right,
right,
right.
Uh,
the fighter in the cage.
So a professor rather in the cage.
I got your book right here and I was
fascinated when I heard the concept and,
uh,
even more fascinated to
talk to you about this.
You decided to write a book about taking
up mixed martial arts and competing.
Yeah.
What,
what caused this,
this bug?
Well,
I was working as a English instructor
at a small Liberal Arts college and
western Pennsylvania,
just outside of Pittsburgh.
And I was pushing up on middle age.
I was,
I think I was 38 and a half at the time.
And I was,
yeah,
I don't know why I did that.
It's like five year old,
you know,
I don't know why I did the
little kids in my house be,
that's why I do.
Um,
so I was 38 and a half at
the time and I was sort of,
I dunno,
as career wasn't going that well.
I had never made an under the tenure
track and it looked like I was never going
to.
So I sort of needed something new in life.
And one day I'm at my office hours and
I happened to look out the front window
and they used to be this auto part store
across the street about as far away as
a not gonna hit it with
a snowball if I threw it.
And this new business had moved in and
it was called Mark Schrader's Academy of
mixed martial arts.
And I said stood there at the window
and I could see the guys in the cage see
seemed dancing,
hitting,
tackling,
rolling.
And I had this unexpected
emotion and the emotion was envy.
I envied them.
They seem so alive over there.
So courageous.
I felt like I was sorta rotting away,
you know,
in my life and my cubicle.
Um,
and so I had this sort of funny thought
into my head and his thought was this a
joke at my own expense?
And the joke was,
wouldn't it be funny if I went
across the street and join them?
You know me cause I'm an,
I have this incredibly civilized job.
I've literally never
been in a fight before.
I'm almost 40 and I'm very good shape.
Um,
and then the next thought was,
well,
you know,
maybe there's a book in that,
it's sort of nonfiction
version of fight club.
I go across the street,
I tried to learn how to fight.
And along the way though,
I'd be asking these sort of big,
deep,
eternal questions about the role that
violence has played in human life.
Now there's a difference between
violence in terms of like people perceive
violences Vic,
there's being a victim.
Yes.
And that's the violence that I think that
everybody has a problem with what you
are engaging in his martial arts and the,
although violent action
happens in martial art overall,
it sounds contradictory.
Yes.
Not necessarily about violence.
Yeah,
I think that's exactly right.
And that was my journey.
So I go,
you know,
when I'm first looking at the
cage from across the street,
I'm looking at it with all the stereotypes
that most outsiders have about the
sport.
And to me it looks really,
really violent.
Um,
I assume that the guys over
there must be of a screw loose.
They must be savages.
Um,
and so I went over there to test a theory.
The theory was,
well,
you know,
there's a,
at the core of human nature and mixed
martial arts is a perfect metaphor for it,
for this violence at the
heart of human nature.
And then I go over there
and I find that my,
my theory isn't very good.
Um,
and what's happening over there?
It's rough.
It's often bloody and painful,
but it's not really quite even violence.
I agree.
You know,
because the emotions
behind it are not angry.
Emotions are not,
they're not the emotions of a,
of violence or rage.
You know,
there's the,
the basic,
uh,
competitive emotions.
And it's also in order to
achieve a very high level,
you have to achieve
something of a zen state.
And that Zen state can
be fucked up by emotion.
Yeah.
It'd be tripped up.
Your training can be tripped up.
You decisions made under
the duress of emotion,
the worst decisions.
Right.
Yeah.
That was one of the things that,
uh,
the instructor that the main instructor
had gotten a mark Schrader warned.
That's about all the time
simply because guys get mad,
they get hit and they get mad.
You know,
it's like don't get mad.
It ruins everything.
You know,
you don't,
you make bad decisions.
You also get tired,
tired.
You have to get mad.
You get,
you also really get mad when you
chase someone to try to get back half.
Right.
Then you have bad management of energy.
There's,
there's so much involved in any
sort of martial arts competition,
any,
any sort of martial arts training that
you don't see unless you engage in it.
Yeah.
It was tremendously valuable to me to
do this because at times I thought,
well,
you know,
I'm not the first writer who
had the idea to go and get,
get in a fight and write about it.
You know,
George Plimpton did it same.
Sheridan did and we've had
shared it on your show.
He wrote a great book about
it and a couple of other guys.
Um,
so I wasn't the first to do it,
but,
and so as a sort of publicity stunt,
that's not really why I did it.
I did it because you really don't know
anything about it unless you'd done it.
Unless you've gone over there and gotten
into the cage and been sort of locked
up inside there,
they literally fuck you
up in there half naked,
you know,
and you're with this other
guy and this other guy,
it's really scary.
You know,
he's a savage killer and the
only way he get out of that cage,
it's just somehow survive.
These next few minutes you're going to,
you're going to spend with this guy.
So there's an intensity to
that thing that you know,
is there when you watch
it from the outside,
but it's much different
to actually feel it,
to feel what's actually happening to you,
to feel what it's like to get
punched in the face really hard.
Um,
it was a tremendously educational
experience to actually do it.
Did it change the way?
Like did you watch martial arts before
that or were you like really an outsider
when you,
if,
did you watch any UFC matches?
Dude,
I've been a fan forever.
Forever.
Uh,
but you still had like some preconceived
notions when you saw the change?
Yeah,
I wanted to figure things out about it.
Like why do I watch this?
You know,
because when I first started watching it,
I had a really good excuse.
I was in my early twenties,
it was about 1995 and I was a committed
but basically an APP to karate student.
And the UFC was a tremendous education
about what worked in a fight and what
absolutely did not.
And most of the stuff that I was learning
in my karate class is absolutely did
not work.
You know what I mean?
And,
uh,
so I,
I was not new to the UFC was
not new to cage fighting,
but I had a very much of an
outsider's perspective on it.
And,
um,
and I was confused about what draws
people to these kinds of spectacles.
What draws people not only
to compete in the cage.
That's an interesting question,
but also what draws people to watch
combat sports or watch other forms of
violence back to call
people who are decent,
civilized human beings.
Why do we want to watch this stuff now?
When you were practicing karate,
like how long did you practice for?
I was like,
maybe like two years.
And I gave it up because of the USC.
I gave it up because of the UFC.
Yeah,
we missed the boat when
Machida came along,
then all of a sudden people
started practicing karate again.
Well,
yeah,
it's true.
It's true.
I love the chair.
Absolutely.
As long as you,
as long as it's,
as long as you're mixing it into a system
rather than sticking with coke Oshan
karate,
which is what I had.
Um,
and so my school was very
purist and when I said,
when did my sensai and said,
hey,
you know,
since a,
uh,
in a very careful,
you know,
there's this,
there's authority in these dough Joe's,
there's tradition that you
question at your peril.
Um,
and so I went in and said,
yeah,
you know,
since they bill,
uh,
I've been watching these tapes.
So washing my blockbuster blockbuster
tapes of these UFC fights.
And long story short is guys like us.
They're not just losing,
they're getting slaughtered,
they're getting massacred.
You know,
they get a couple of feeble punches off.
They get tackled to the ground,
beaten half to death.
And so I say to him,
you know,
what do we do?
What do you do if you're
taking down in a fight?
And He'd be like,
you look at me and be,
it's obvious.
Just,
just don't get taken down.
It's that easy.
Oh.
And,
and I,
and right then it hit me that he
didn't know anything about fighting.
He didn't know how often
fights go to the ground.
He didn't know that not getting
taken down is a martial art.
Yes.
You know,
and he didn't know that.
If you don't,
if you're not training for that,
if you're not drilling it,
you're going to get taken down.
And if you haven't drilled
ways to stand back up again,
you're going to stay down.
Yeah.
So what I realized then that that was,
we were,
we were like larpers
live action role playing,
you know what I mean?
No.
Larping is no,
but I do now it's live d and d you go
off into the woods with your friends and
you play d and d live.
Yeah,
it's pretty awesome.
It's awful.
But that's what we were doing.
Basically.
We are larping as,
as you know,
Samurai.
Um,
and uh,
so after that was pretty
disillusioned and I,
and I gave it up.
I would've gone into it earlier,
but it took a long time for MMA and
Bjj to make it to my neck of the woods.
It's been out here in La and in
New York City for a long time,
but I've always kind of lived in
podunk towns and it's only in,
it's only,
again,
not until 2010 or 2011 that I had
the option to do this where I really,
so you know,
Jujitsu until 2010 or 11.
What is this?
You're still the same place
outside of Pittsburgh?
Yeah.
How far is Pittsburgh?
Pittsburgh is about a half hour,
but even Pittsburgh,
Pittsburgh had one BJJ school it,
but that was all,
you know,
there wasn't,
there wasn't.
There was a fight club that had gone out
of business and him may club that had
gone out of business.
They get their back now
and it ends up grace.
He has a school there now.
So there is good stuff there now,
but it's very difficult to make
money teaching MMA very difficult.
You can do much better teaching
Jujitsu or teaching taekwondo.
Even our karate.
I think that's right.
Yeah.
I had a similar um,
martial arts upbringing.
Yeah.
I started out in taekwondo but
dedicated my entire life to it.
And then when I started kickboxing,
that was my eye opening.
It was before even grappling,
grappling them as my second eye opening.
My first eye opening was kickboxing
because I realize and then also just
training straight boxing rules that help
terrible my hands were cause taekwondo
was so kicked the trivia.
Yeah.
It was just all about kicking.
And when guys are only kicking you,
there's a lot of things you can get away
with that you can't get away with when
they're punching you.
And I had this like big
enlightenment moment like,
man,
I've been wasting my time and not really,
it turned down in the long run cause
I learned a lot of things and I,
I developed dexterity
that it's very unusual.
It's deck.
Yeah.
Flexibility.
But anybody could develop flexibility
is the dexterity is unusual.
Like the ability to throw
kicks in positions in ways
that a lot of other people
can't.
And it's just because that's all you do.
You're throwing a lot of kicks.
Yeah.
And so there's a lot of
guys that took that style.
Like Anderson Silva is one of them and
started out as a taekwondo guy and then
eventually developed all
the martial arts skills.
Take down defense wrestling
and Jujitsu and whatnot.
But yeah,
when the UFC came around,
most people who are on the outside,
they,
they'll look at it like,
I've,
I've had so many people say like,
that's not martial arts,
it's a sports martial sport and there's
all this silliness attached to it.
But what they need to know is
that no one knew when I was a kid.
No one knew until 93 no one knew.
They didn't know that it was
so easy to take you down.
And when they did take you down,
he would just break your arm.
Like they're just strangle you and sat
and it's like no one had any idea how
vulnerable they were.
I know it's,
it was a shock,
right?
Wasn't it in shock.
Total shock.
And I watch,
I mean,
I remember seeing the first couple of
them and I watched them religiously.
At first I'd,
I'd,
I'd pause,
I'd slowed down,
I rewind and watch the movie.
We tried to etch it,
you know,
into my memory banks.
But I,
but I,
I watched with a sinking feeling like,
oh my God,
this is not at all.
Not at all.
I started you Jitsu almost
immediately after discovering it.
I found out about it in 94
or five I think I found it.
It started out in 93 and I think I
came out to La in [inaudible] 94 and
somewhere in mid 94 I've found out about
the UFC and I didn't see the first one.
I saw like the second one
and I watched it on video.
That's what I did too.
Yeah,
like a VHS tape video.
Exactly.
Yeah.
I used to hang out in that
section of video store.
I still remember it.
I would learn it.
They're dangerous.
He like like little to large lobby lurking
there like like you know when you're
in the porno section or
something because it was like,
it was like UFC video with WWF,
a death faces.
Death
was in that section.
There were all lumped in together.
That's what it was with.
Yeah.
I remember I was training
at the jet center,
which is a famous
kickboxing gym and Van Eyes.
It was right before it went under
because they'd gotten damaged in the
earthquake.
And then once a rain came
after the earthquake,
they got massive flood damage
and they eventually went under.
But before they went under,
that was where when I
first moved to California,
I started working out and Benny the jet
or key does is like one of the pioneers
of not just kickboxing but incorporating
low kicks and fighting against the ties
and the Japanese with their low kicks and
then fighting in like sort of no holds
barred.
Tournament's back then.
And Benny had this,
uh,
you know,
in his,
his,
uh,
his brother in law,
I guess blinky Rodriguez is a famous
kickboxers well would teach classes there.
And who's a crazy environment cause
he a blinky had some family tragedy
involving gang violence.
So he had a lot of gang members that
would a train there and work out there.
So like,
like you'd have these guys,
like I remember this one guy had this
really shitty like prison tattoo on his
back that said like whatever
gang member was like,
love block does.
And then underneath it
it said fuck the rest,
like tattooed big on his back,
like a 12 year old drew it
in there and I was like,
oh Christ.
Like this is where I'm working out.
And um,
you know,
when we take classes,
those guys and spar with those guys,
it was just very disconcerting.
Like you didn't want to beat up a gang
member and they get shot in the parking
lot,
but the um,
the,
the place was abuzz about these tapes.
Like people had found out about him.
Everybody's like,
you see this shit,
but it's like damn,
this motherfucker just grabs
people and drag them to the ground,
chokes him and everybody wanted
to talk about it and it was just,
it was just no sense.
It didn't,
not only didn't make any sense,
everybody was like,
what are we doing here?
What do,
what do,
what do we doing with our skillset?
Like,
cause this shit going to work.
Like what if we want to
do one of those dudes?
And so I went to a cross and Gracie's,
which was a [inaudible] know about it.
I found out about the gym from,
there was a show called,
I think it was called extreme
fighting championships.
There was a very small
at John Perretti was the,
the the matchmaker and he was producing
it think it's called extreme combat
stream something stream.
I don't remember a lot of extreme uh,
promotions.
Yeah.
But they had a,
a montage,
like a training montage thing
for one of the fighters and uh,
he was training at Carlson Gracie's and
I knew that Mario Sperry train there and
he was like,
one of the big guys at the
time and Marillo Bustamonte
was Dan Vitor Belfort was
there before he made his UFC debut.
I came in there right when
he was making his debut.
He had just,
I got there when he was about to fight
John Hess in Hawaii and he fought Ho John
has in Hawaii who had fought in the UFC
and beat the fuck out of them in about
10 seconds.
It was like one of the
craziest fights ever.
He got on top of them and just,
I think he went and needed a belly on
him and just uncorked about 50 punches to
his face.
Like nobody had seen anybody like
Vittorio was a horrible monster.
He's still fighting fucking weekend,
which is so crazy.
Vito is fighting this
weekend for the title.
Yeah.
Madness.
But um,
so that's,
I,
I just was in the,
is immediately upon going to Carlson
Gracie's I was just manhandled and thrown
around like a little baby
and strangled left and right.
I was like,
Jesus Christ,
I'm fucking helpless.
I had this delusional idea that I could,
I could defend myself,
but as a white belt in Jujitsu,
even with a year of high school wrestling,
I kinda like knew how to wrestle a little.
I knew how to like get on top of guy
and then I get triangled their farm,
barter guillotined and they'd
take my back and you know,
I didn't know what the
fuck to do with the gay,
the gay was ridiculous,
crazy,
wrapping me up in that thing and just,
ugh.
It was so humiliating.
Yeah.
I'll never forget it,
but also so enlightening.
And for you going from this karate
background to then entering into mixed
martial arts training,
like what was,
why I'd never been punched
in the face for one thing.
It all your karate training.
No one punched you in the face.
We always threw punches to the
chest because it's Kyokushin.
Kio Yeah.
Yeah.
Wow.
So you never,
you never,
I mean that's boxing gloves
on and fucked around.
Maybe we did,
but not for real.
I mean the level,
the,
the intensity of sparring at the
[inaudible] was so much more intense.
So maybe we put boxing gloves on and,
and,
and threw some punches,
but very soft.
Wow.
And there was,
there's days that the MMA
gym where it's a very,
very close to being,
you know,
a real fight in there,
not fin is a real fun.
I was pretty close to
being in a real fight.
Yeah.
It's painful.
Ask as in,
um,
and um,
the Daniel Cormier who is
also fighting this weekend,
um,
Courtney said,
sometimes mean Keynes bar
and sometimes we fight.
Fuck.
He said that in the old days we fought,
we always fought.
Now sometimes he's bar.
Well that's,
that's a big concern today.
The big concern is like how much do you
take out of yourself in the gym is how
much,
how much is it necessary though?
Like in order to prepare to be comfortable
in the cage and to fight at your
best,
how much do you have to
take out of your system?
Man,
it is a tough decision because
if they go the go easy,
they're afraid that their guys go,
I'm really horrible at the time.
I think go hard.
There's a,
yeah,
what does it,
it's practically a coin flip,
but they're going to get through to the
fight without getting injured in some
way.
Well,
one of the best gyms,
um,
American Kickboxing Academy,
uh,
Dana White,
it was just talking about how they train,
like cavemen,
like to get,
get out of stone age.
And they kind of said,
look,
you know,
you kind of don't realize what's
necessary to prepare for fights,
but then you look at the amount
of guys that get hurt there.
Yeah,
it is pretty crazy.
but you look at the amount of
guys that have really good there.
Luke Rockhold,
Daniel core,
me a Cain Velasquez like fuck.
You can't argue with that success.
And it seems to me like there
is no easy way out of this.
Does no,
I don't think you can train light.
The problem
is like,
uh,
other sports would have this
problems that they have.
They have an authority that governs it
and makes everyone behave the same way.
So the NFL,
for instance,
for the NCAA,
like football teams for instance,
there are allowed to practice so
many hours a week and that's it.
Really?
Yeah.
It's by a rule,
you know,
you're not allowed that you put,
you put you in your 20 or 30
hours a week and then that's it.
You're not allowed to train on your own.
Why?
Because he could.
That's the problem.
You guys will cheat and go.
Yeah.
Well that's a problem with fighting.
Fighting is a team sport.
No,
no findings.
An individual's right to
anytime anybody goes well,
the people in the NFL,
people,
the NFL,
first of all that fucking whistle
blows and you get a nice juicy break.
Yeah,
I mean now you get to catch your breath,
walk around offsides you
got that guy talks timeout.
He says a bunch of shit that went wrong
and everybody complains and it's a joke.
If you compare the amount of effort
you have to put forth and an NFL,
sure the collisions are horrific.
Shore you.
You mean you got to work out hard
to be that fucking big and strong.
There's no doubt about it.
But as for like the life and death
experience of being in the cage,
fuck
man.
No,
I don't think,
I think comparison is nothing.
There's nothing.
Now how did you,
did you start off with
the beginner classes?
Like how did you,
how did you enter into this?
No,
I mean basically this gym,
it's a small gym,
you know,
it's a small town.
How many,
how many students were,
ah,
it would vary,
you know,
like,
it's like you said,
and it is a tough business and
MMA gym with a tough business.
And so it might be booming in
popularity as a spectator sport.
It doesn't mean most guys want to
get in there and start training.
Right.
I mean,
cause it doesn't look like all that much
fun opening up a base jumping school.
Yeah,
pretty much.
Yeah.
Um,
so,
uh,
I think he expected as a lot of
guys who opened those gyms to that,
that the level of popularity
as a spectator sport,
it would track with the level
of a participate participation.
Um,
so maybe like most nights
to be 15 guys there,
something like that.
Too Bad.
That's not too bad.
Yeah.
Did you ever have an issue with the guys
who were more experienced beating up on
the guys who so
weren't,
I mean,
honestly,
sometimes,
but honestly,
not for the most part.
Uh,
you know,
there's a very clear pecking order
emerges in an intimate jam or any kind of
martial arts gym almost from day one.
And people have a very good sense of very,
very good sense of who would kick his
ass if it came down to a real fight.
Um,
and so for the most part,
the big guys don't bully
or oppress the little guys.
It was no glory in it.
And the little guys also know
not to antagonize the big guys,
you know,
they give them respect,
they give them submissive body language.
You know,
one time I was going to fight,
uh,
or spar this big heavyweight in my
channel and we often had this part of our
weight class because it is a smaller gym.
So this guy weighs like 270 pounds.
He's a competition fight or I'm terrified.
Um,
and in the moment before the bell rings,
I go right up to him and I hug him,
bury my head right in his fragrant,
meaty cleavage.
And I say,
come on Clark,
I got a family.
You know,
I'm after that,
you know,
you didn't exactly go easy on me,
but he let me live.
So and that happens,
you know,
I was pretty explicit about it,
but I think that kind of language,
that kind of communication
is going on a lot at the gym.
Yeah,
it certainly is.
It does in Jujitsu as well.
Like you'll see some guys
that like as the rolling,
they're just more
submissive to other guys.
You know,
like when someone is more dominant,
it's like you,
there's just certain
things you don't even try.
Like you'll automatically
go in defensive mode,
which is also very dangerous for the guy
who's the best guy in the gym because
you can get a very inflated sense
of your abilities if you're always,
it's like there's certain finders that
fought in lower level organizations and
then came over to the UFC and
as they came over to the UFC,
one of the first things that was clear
was that they had never faced another
killer.
Yeah.
Like they might be a killer themselves.
But they had never faced another killer
and then wouldn't face a killer in the
UFC.
They'd be like,
oh,
this is what it's like
to fight me this song.
And you,
you would often find out who's
got it and who doesn't have it.
Sure.
I might tell him.
That's definitely true.
Yeah.
They call them the better guys there.
I don't hit those guys harder than face.
No Way.
Yeah.
You don't want to,
no way.
Even you authorize them to hit you hard.
Yeah.
We'll see.
I'll be Carlos Condit said
that once he did this,
um,
uh,
this thing,
for the military and did
this some sparring and stuff
with some of the military
guys and he's real clear.
He goes,
hey man,
he goes,
we can have some fun here.
Just hit me as hard as
you want to get hit.
Exactly.
When you're that good.
And you could say,
just hit me as hard as you want to get it.
Don't hit that guy hard.
Trust me.
But that's,
you know,
it's,
it's finding that perfect balance of,
of competition,
but have also,
you know,
like you got to figure out how to
not kill each other inside the gym.
You gotta compete and push each other.
And oftentimes it's just a matter of just
pulling back on shots of not trying to
knock each other out because the guys
who tried to knock each other out,
man,
that fucking,
that style of sparring that just cannot,
cannot maintain.
No,
I think it's really dominant.
There are guys in my gym like that guys
who apparently can't pull the punch
either by either by lack of athleticism.
You know what I mean?
It's kind of a hard thing to throw the
punch as hard as you can do there are for
that and then pull it
at the very last second.
That's kind of an athletic thing
to be able to pull off and,
and I would hate hate is
partnering with those guys.
Yeah,
there's always a guy like that.
There's guys like that in Jujitsu
to that guys would never spar with.
There was this one,
dude,
no need to name names,
but at a John Jacques Machado is,
we'd all just get away from this
guy because if you sparred with him,
if he caught you in anything,
he's going to fuck your
arm up fucking neck up.
Like he just would not let go and he
didn't know how to not yank on things.
And then there's other guys that were way
better than him that you never worried
about.
Like you might get,
you might get tapped like,
yeah,
like if you roll with
John Jacques Machado,
even if you get tapped,
it's so controlled.
Right?
Like you never get hurt,
you know,
like he'll be wraps you up in a triangle
or takes your back or something like
that.
Like he's in control the entire time.
There's no yanking or weird shit
twisting that you didn't expect.
And those are like the dangerous guys,
like the really strong blue belts.
Yeah,
that's true.
That's true.
Yeah.
Those are the guys that much them to,
or there was guys who were like,
there's guys that can't quite spar
than then you have to fight them.
You know what?
I mean,
you're going to come so hard.
You almost have to fight them.
And that I don't,
I don't want to do,
are you still doing it?
Are you still,
after you wrote the book?
I did it,
you know,
this was a big thing that this was the
big surprise for me about doing this
whole project was,
again,
I wa I look at it from across the street.
I'd always been a fan,
but I never really wanted to do it myself.
I wanted to do Jujitsu,
but I didn't really want
to be a cage fighter.
Um,
it didn't look like fun to me.
It looked like about
as much fun as torture.
You know what I mean?
It looks scary and painful.
Uh,
and the biggest shock for
me was that I loved it.
I loved it.
Um,
so I expected to do it for a year
and then to quit the absolute second.
My fight was over.
Um,
you know,
that's it.
I'm retired.
I'll go write the book.
Uh,
but I,
uh,
I kept doing it for a
couple of years longer,
um,
because I really loved it.
I loved the Camaraderie.
I love the challenge of it.
Love the way it made me feel.
I love the way,
you know,
gave me this ability to live
a sort of head long life,
you know,
for a couple hours a week is all.
What do you mean by headlong?
I don't know.
I had this restraint in my life.
I'm a,
I'm a professor,
you know,
I had this really a dull
life and a lot of ways.
And then just for a few hours a week,
I go in and I take these
risks and then Jim and I,
and I experienced these
big emotions and these big,
these big highs,
you know?
And then about a year ago I was so beat
up that I really just couldn't continue
anymore.
And giving up was one of the
hardest things I've ever done.
Uh,
it was like,
you know,
I kind of felt like this romance in my
life had come to an end and I was too
brittle and too old,
you know,
to recapture it.
What was the issue like physically?
I always expected for it to end badly.
You know,
I knew it was kind of pushed
my luck and I figured that,
I figured I'd go out on
my shield at some point.
You'll go out on a stretcher after some
horrible head injury or blow out my knee
or something like that.
It wasn't like that though.
It was more like a,
a an accumulation of little things,
a rickety old man stuff,
you know,
you just get older and you start picking
up these little injuries and they don't
go away.
Uh,
so I got,
you know,
I kept getting turf toe from kicks and
from getting stuck on the mat and that
turned into arthritis at some point.
And I've pulled my groin bad and that's
been bad and then mess up my neck one
time.
And uh,
it was never been quite the same,
just,
just got rickety and a pardon reason I
had started going to hot yoga as we said
before,
is in hopes of carrying all this stuff,
you know,
getting any physically health,
getting my flexibility better
so I can't get back in the gym.
I don't ever want to do hardcore and
the main sparring anymore.
I want to get hit in the head anymore.
Uh,
but I do want to get back into
the grappling elements of it.
Yeah.
We were talking about it before the
podcast started that I've become addicted
the last few weeks to yoga.
Yeah,
me too.
Yeah.
It just kept,
I,
I've got this reoccurring,
um,
uh,
issue.
Well,
I have,
I have a pulled muscle in my,
but very uncomfortable to talk about it.
Um,
but it's,
uh,
it's,
it's aggravated when I throw kicks and
so I wasn't throwing kicks for awhile,
but there's certain punches
when I'd just push off of it.
It just is something about exploding.
So I was like,
man,
I gotta stretch out my
back so he's fucked up.
And so I started taking a hot yoga like a,
about a week and a half ago.
And,
uh,
like almost immediately I found
out that it calmed me down.
Like almost immediately.
It was like my stress level
just dropped tremendously.
I mean,
I had done it before,
but I've been real inconsistent about it.
So I'm trying to do four
days a week for like a year.
That's my,
that's my goal too.
I'm like,
well can you do it on back to back days?
Yeah.
You can often feel so tired
from it on the second day.
Muscularly tired.
I mean,
the thing that I didn't expect
about Yoga is how difficult it is.
Yeah.
I mean I knew it was like,
I thought you were,
I thought it was be in a hot room.
Stretching.
That's what I thought it was.
I know what I mean.
But it is,
I mean the level of exertion
is really extraordinary.
It's harder than a lot of Jujitsu
classes and people are going to say,
get the fuck out of here.
It's,
if I have to roll with five blue belts
that are my size or do a class in hot
yoga,
I guarantee you it's harder to do yoga.
Yeah.
Cause if a guy's under my level,
I can pretty much control what happens.
You know?
I could,
I could hold positions,
I could choose to take
breaks and you know,
I can mount them and just relax,
you know?
Yeah.
He's like,
you can't,
he can't do that.
If you're fighting for your life.
No,
you can get someone good if you're
grappling with someone really good.
Jujitsu is harder because
it's fighting to the death.
You know,
if there's someone who's
just just a little bit better
than you or a solid notch
better than you and they're
trying to kill you and you're,
you're constantly on the,
they're not good enough that
you're in total defensive mode,
you're still,
oh,
that's,
you're still in the game.
Gets a heart attack
stages where you're like,
this might end right here.
This whole fucking life on this
planet might end right here for me.
It would be a good look.
That'd be a good death for you.
It's not the worst death.
Um,
but yoga is almost as difficult.
It's really hard.
I mean,
I was going to write something about it,
like I might ride it still like a blog
entry about how there's this life or
death struggle that's going on,
these hot rooms all over the country
and no one knows how difficult it really
is.
Everybody thinks it's like really easy
because a bunch of women are doing it.
Exactly.
I think guys don't get it at all
cause I'm always there and it's,
and I kind of like the,
the female environment of it.
Yeah.
I like that.
It's such a big transition from the gym,
you know,
where like it's
noncompetitive in the hole.
Even if it was a male teacher,
the whole culture is still female,
you know?
It's like,
uh,
it's a feminine culture.
It's like it's none of the
macho stuff is going right.
Right.
You're not,
you're not trying to vanquish the room
at hot yoga like you will be possibly if
you were at the gym,
you know?
Um,
so I'm,
I just dig it and I think it's a main
thing that people don't get about it
because I would've thought I
would've had the same stereotypes.
I think a lot of people have.
That's kind of a sissy thing to do.
There's nothing sissy about it.
It's really,
it's really,
uh,
it's really a hard thing.
Yeah.
It just has a weird connotation.
For some reason.
It was a weird,
we have this weird perception of
it because we see girls and tights.
How could they be working?
Exactly.
It's ridiculous.
I want you to check.
I wonder if they're not,
I wonder if I do get the feeling
that I am working harder because,
because I'm newer and I have to work
really hard to get into these positions
because I'm not sure I'm
not my flexibility socks.
And when he thinks women,
a lot of them are super flexible and
they seem to get into those positions
pretty effortlessly and hold them with
less vibration than I'm holding them.
You know what mean?
Some for sure,
but some,
I mean there's this one lady that uh,
I go to this class and she's,
she's got to take a break.
Like every other post,
she's barely getting through it.
She's very out of shape and
she's attempting to do this
very difficult class and
there's certain certain things
when I do it where I'm like,
fucking,
I could barely hang in here
until this guy calls it.
No,
me too.
But in other ones it's a breeze where
other people were really struggling.
It depends on the instructor you mean?
No,
no,
no.
The flexibility.
I like,
I have a lot of flexibility in my legs,
like kicking flexibility and so there's
certain poses where everybody else is
struggling and I'm taking a break.
I'm like,
whew,
I can relax here.
Arms back.
Yeah,
that can do all that.
But the big one is like
stretching my legs out,
putting my body forward,
or with a lot of people
they're holding it,
holding it.
I'm like,
I can go to sleep here.
So it's nice.
I get little breaks now for me,
I'm fighting,
I'm fighting for my life in that position.
And having that voice in my head is is,
you know,
like you can do it pause.
But then there's other ones
where I'm just fucking dying.
You know?
It's,
it's really difficult.
But you know,
again,
I think there's a balance issue and
I think when you're all the time,
all the explosion lifting weights,
kettlebells,
yeah,
yeah.
I think it's good to do like
static tension relieving,
long holding those poses,
stretching,
elongating the muscle,
stretching out all the tissue,
stretching out the hamstrings
and the back muscles.
And there's so much,
so much stretching going on.
I realize when I'm doing it,
I'm like,
this is,
I don't ever do this.
I said,
I never lengthen everything out.
Everything is just getting compressed.
Everything is,
everything is explosion and all this
fucking heavyweight and there's a,
I think you need balance.
I don't think it's,
you should have only yoga.
Like I think it's,
I think it's good to put weight on your
body and your muscles because it's good
for your density,
your bones.
It maintains mass.
It,
it keeps you from getting frail as,
especially as you get older.
But I think stretching and yoga positions
should be almost mandatory for people
to get their shit together.
You know?
It's,
it's,
it makes you way calmer.
I don't know why.
I mean I wish w I w I wonder if it's just
physical tension being released or if
just stretching itself,
if there's something in the act of
doing so that just when it's over,
everything else just seems
like calm and relaxed.
Like the difficulty of those poses.
Yeah.
I always felt like it was just,
it burns through so much energy.
You don't have anything less to tor left
to torture yourself with afterwards.
You know,
the,
the anxiety's kind of burned through
and now I had the same sense.
You did it the first time I did.
I was like,
oh my God,
this is the healthiest thing
I've ever done in my life.
How long you've been doing it?
Like I've done like 10 classes,
so I'm still at that stage of like,
you know,
converts people,
you know.
Oh yeah.
I'm a blue belt disease.
Like just before you get a blue belt
Jujitsu guys just to want to talk about
anything but Jujitsu.
So you want to do it to a point where
you get healthy enough to go back to
grappling.
Yeah.
I'd like to get back into it.
The Gym.
Yeah.
I miss,
I miss the guys.
I miss.
It was a good thing for me.
You know?
Uh,
Anthony Bordain just cut into Jujitsu.
Do you know what I did that,
yeah,
I didn't know that.
Yeah.
It's amazing.
Yeah,
I know he loves it too.
I met him,
that fucking guy,
blue belt disease.
He's still smoked a few cigarettes.
When I met him,
drank crazy.
Lee has he quit drinking a lot?
Yeah,
he quit smoking.
He quit smoking when he had his daughter.
Um,
which was just right.
Right.
Cause right around when
I was meeting him and um,
was just eating whatever the
fuck you wanted to getting,
you know,
a belly and drinking all the time
and traveling around the world.
And then his wife is a maniac.
His wife is a Jujitsu fiend,
but I see a guy like that
and I'm like at 58 years old.
Like how,
how much can his body [inaudible]
he's doing it like twice a day.
I wonder if he's doing any yoga
or anything to counteract just,
I dunno,
just age related degeneration.
I don't know.
I often wonder that about,
about,
about that myself,
I wonder if like the fact that he wasn't
athletic for most of his life means
that he hit,
he hadn't put a lot of
hard miles on himself.
That could be true.
My,
now you've got a lot of
hard miles on yourself.
I got quite a few hard miles.
I'm less now,
you know?
Yeah.
I have a lot of fucking
hard miles on this body.
It's a lot of surgeries,
a lot of injuries and
but works amazingly well.
But a lot of that is because I
don't have a conventional job.
I was thinking that today
when I did that class,
I was like,
how many fucking people
have an hour and a half,
you know,
the middle of the day or at nine o'clock
in the morning to go in there and you
know,
stretch out in the fucking sweat
box for an hour and a half.
Most people just don't have that time.
And then when you get home you have,
you know,
your family and bills and blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah and you have all
this shit to deal with.
Most people don't have the time to to put
in for body maintenance for the proper
body maintenance.
It's very true.
It comes down to the conversation
with a friend about nutrition.
Like they were asking
me like what kind of,
which kind of supplement should I get,
what should I do?
And I said,
well,
one of the first thing you should do
is find a qualified doctor and get your
blood work done.
Find out where your
nutrition levels are at,
what your vitamin levels are.
Like,
let's find out,
like eat what you normally eat.
Don't get,
you don't have to get
crazy and try to fix it,
but eat what you normally eat.
And then let's find out what,
what do you need?
You know,
most people like,
oh,
that's how much time.
Yeah.
Then all the energy and time for
a doctor and do the research.
It's a lot of work.
It's,
it's jobs or bullshit.
That's the real problem.
They're bullshit.
I mean,
part of what you were feeling when you
saw those guys across the street and
there were there were living their life.
You realize that you were contained.
Yeah.
A box and the professor in the cage,
the cage is the cage.
It's fighting cage,
but it's also my office.
You know,
my,
my cubicle where I worked.
And so the book is about
getting out of that cubicle.
You know,
I was,
you know,
getting,
getting out of my academic career
if this thing sold like crazy,
would you be willing to
write their professor in the
Mat and enter into Jujitsu?
Yeah,
for sure.
Man.
Professor in the Yoga Room.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Adventures as a,
uh,
want,
want to be Yogi start a franchise.
Yeah,
definitely.
Now,
um,
what is boring about teaching English?
It wasn't,
it was boring.
I don't know.
You know,
I was teaching a lot of writing classes,
uh,
especially freshmen writing and freshmen
writing and my college was mandatory.
Uh,
which means that everyone
there is a captive and most
college courses you get to
take whatever you want to
take cause there's electives,
you're not forced to be anywhere.
This is a class you're forced to be.
And so I was teaching freshman composition
over and over and over again to
students who just didn't,
couldn't care less,
you know.
Um,
and so that was lame.
Or the main problem though
was that I was an adjunct.
You don't an adjunct.
Is that just like if not a
full time faculty member?
Um,
so,
you know,
for,
for like,
almost 10 years,
I'm making about 16 grand a year,
you know,
uh,
making,
you know,
just kind of,
kind of chasing this dream of being a,
a boyhood dream,
really of being a college professor,
of being a scholar.
I wanted to be that guy,
like the guy who makes some small but
meaningful contribution to knowledge.
And I had been chasing that dream for a
long time and writing books and tune it,
written the articles and
doing all kinds of stuff.
But it just wasn't,
my,
my research was a little bit
nonconventional and it just wasn't,
I wasn't making it,
you know what I mean?
And so,
uh,
and I just didn't have
the courage to quit.
It wasn't,
I don't know if it's a
courage thing or if it was a,
uh,
a desire thing.
I don't,
I don't like,
I don't like quitting on something
that I've invested in target.
You know,
it's like,
it's like if you're gambling,
you know,
you throw money in the pot,
you don't want to fucking fold,
even though,
you know,
you should fold.
And so when I started,
when I went across the
street that first time,
and I made that joke at my own expense of,
it wouldn't be funny if I went over there.
Part of it,
part of what was driving
me to cross over there,
it was a career suicide fantasy.
I was thinking to myself,
why you apparently don't have the
courage to quit your job and move on to
something else?
Maybe you can do something offensive
enough to people in your profession that
will get you fired.
I'm like,
so if I showed up in the cage,
everybody in my department
will be able to honest to God,
like up from the poems they were reading,
you know,
reading their poems,
they look up and they'd be able
to see me right across the street,
you know,
uh,
engaged in bloodsport and they don't
really approve of a bloodsport and English
departments.
What has the reaction
been amongst your peers?
Um,
okay.
Career suicide,
career,
suicide fantasy.
Right,
right.
So I went over there thinking,
ah,
I can't quit me back and get myself fired.
Um,
on my,
on my campus.
Uh,
people were much more tolerant
and open minded than I had hoped.
They didn't get.
They didn't get furious with me.
They didn't,
they didn't try to fire me.
It's because they know me.
They know I'm not a savage animal.
They know,
um,
you know,
the enormity decent human being.
Um,
the,
the bigger question is what,
what effect will have within the larger
profession will be an effective career
suicide strategy.
Once other people in the
profession get ahold of the book.
And I do think probably
it'll be a success.
That's a career suicide strategy.
Uh,
about two weeks after the book came out,
this,
uh,
article came out about
me and about the book,
uh,
in this magazine that no one reads in
the real world called the chronicle of
higher education,
but it's the main trade
magazine for academia.
And the book comes off pretty
much as a glorification of Macho,
barbarism and their in their,
in their thinking,
you know,
what a dumb,
a dumb glorification of
butchery and barbarism.
He might mean butchery even.
Well,
you just using that word and Sam savagery,
sat,
savagery,
barbarism.
Um,
it sounds like it was written by a pussy.
So
there's a lot of that.
So that could be effective in
ending my career because that,
that's a guy,
like I read about that
and I read the article,
I was like,
I was like I said to my wife like,
okay,
that ends up there.
There it is.
Yeah.
Well written.
Well read.
Did Guy have a points?
No,
I mean,
no.
I mean it's all going to be well written.
We didn't have points
cause he's a good writer,
you know what I mean?
But um,
it's not,
I don't think it's good journalism,
but it's good writing.
Well it's editorial.
I mean,
I mean whenever you're yeah,
it wasn't,
it was a,
it was a feature,
a sort of portrait.
And instead of,
instead of making an actual portrait,
he sort of drew a caricature,
in my opinion,
a caricature of you or have
we and the book and the,
of what you're trying to
accomplish or of the sport itself.
Let me give you one example.
So,
one example,
he quotes in the book is like,
we're at lunch,
you know,
and we're having a nice time.
And,
and,
and at some point I lean across the
table toward him and I say to him like,
this,
you know,
across the table in an
intimidating fashion,
what would it take?
What would I have to say to get
you to punch me in the face?
That would just said to him,
really?
Yeah,
I said it to him,
but if he's 80,
strip out all the damn context.
Right?
So in context that,
you know,
that statement is about me saying how
hard it is to get guys punch you in the
face that men are fairly peaceable,
minutemen avoid conflict.
Um,
they're very fairly prudent
about throwing their,
their,
their fists around.
Most guys will go
to great lengths to find a face saving
way out of a violent confrontation.
So within context,
the,
the statement was almost the
opposite of what it made.
It made it seem like,
right.
So in his words,
you were trying,
you were intimidating him and pretty much,
yeah.
Well maybe that's just how he took it.
Some people are super uncomfortable with
any idea it like any form of conflict,
you know,
and they,
they would like to categorize any,
any kind of violent interaction,
even voluntary violent interaction like
mixed martial arts competition as being
barbaric,
as having no virtue as having no,
no,
there's no nobility.
I,
I get that too.
And I,
I think,
I don't know if it's harder for
you to get into that mind space,
but it's not hard for me to
get into that mind space,
mind space of person who looks at
that and sees no redemption in it.
Nothing good about it.
I don't have a hard time.
It's easy for me to get into.
It sounds crazy because I,
I,
it's my job.
I mean I'm a mixed martial arts
commentator for the university,
but I have a problem with,
I have a problem with the damage.
I have a pro.
I was living three existence.
It's going to ask you about that.
Yeah.
I mean,
I love watching fights.
I have always loved watching fights.
I love that people,
uh,
have this burning desire in them to do
what I think is the most difficult sport
in the world.
I don't think there's anything even close.
I think as far as the
emotions that are invested in,
in,
in trying to win and the debt,
devastating effect of a loss and then
the actual physical damage that you take
along the way you or your vehicle
that you were racing is your own body.
And unlike a race car,
your body will respond
only if you push it.
And Training,
you have to elevate its capacity.
You have to elevate its tolerances and
you have to do that intelligently and it
has to be done in the
watchful eye of trainers.
And along the way,
there's all these variables you have
to take into account strength and
conditioning.
What kind of a body type or
you're dealing with what you know,
what skill set do you have?
What needs to be improved?
Objectivity objectively and analyzing
your strengths and weaknesses,
looking at your skill set,
looking at the weapons that you have that
you need to keep sharp and looking at
ones that you need to acquire.
There's so many variables.
To me it's the ultimate problem solving.
High level competition.
I don't think there's anything like it,
but I have a problem
with a lot of the ass.
I'll have a lot of problem with
a lot of the thuggish behavior.
I have a problem with a,
I mean even though I know a lot of it
is psychological warfare and trying to
intimidate each other,
I have a problem with some of that.
I have a problem with the
damage that guys tick.
I've written a real problem with that.
I have a real problem with
guys not knowing when to
get out with their friends,
telling them,
listen man,
she's got to put together one hard.
Can't be like,
no,
no.
He's been knocked out seven fucking times.
Like No.
He needs to preserve his brain
for the rest of his life.
Have you ever met an old
man that used to fight?
I have.
It's not fun.
It's not fun at all.
It's,
it's very uncomfortable to talk to a guy
who tells the same fucking story over
and over and over and
over and over and over.
Yes.
Yeah.
Yes I do.
And I know UFC fighters who
didn't use to be like that,
who are like that now.
And there's some of my all time favorites.
This is the big question for me.
Let me ask one more question.
The other day on the podcast,
you mentioned a Howard Cosell given up
that work after seeing a particularly
gruesome fight.
Larry Holmes.
Tux Cob.
Yeah.
You ever,
you ever think that could happen to you?
Um,
it's possible.
Yeah.
It's possible that there'll come
a day where I can't do it anymore,
that I don't want to do it anymore.
I'll probably always be a fan.
Um,
uh,
to some extent look,
but like my favorite guys,
mighty mouse,
you know,
people think like my all time favorite
guys are some of the craziest,
like Vandelay Silva is one
of my all time favorite,
just cause his fights were fucking chaos.
You knew if you're going to
watch a Vandelay Silva fight,
that dude across the ring and he's
wiggling his wrists back in the pride days
doing this shit and he wa he,
he,
he was probably one of the
best middleweights ever.
Um,
you know,
or light heavyweight in that
division is two oh three,
but a,
they called it middle weight.
They called,
uh,
the actual called,
yeah,
they called the one 85 pound
division was welterweight,
I think.
Um,
but Vandelay who was just the
opposite of like mighty mouse,
like mighty mouse is my favorite
currently because he fights so fucking
intelligently.
Everything he does,
his movement,
his footwork is positioning.
He's always in condition
is conditioning is insane.
They could just push guys to the point
where they just cannot keep up with him
and his,
just his technical superiority
over all of the competition.
It's just so obvious.
And his work ethic,
his intelligence,
he's a great role model.
When you hear him talk,
he's a very intelligent young man,
but also humble and friendly.
I mean he did.
You see him,
the only thing that tells you that
guy's a martial arts fighters,
his ears.
You look at him,
he seemed so friendly and so nice,
but then he gets in there,
he's the baddest
motherfucker on the world.
Pound for pound in my opinion.
Yeah,
no,
I think he's just 125 pounds.
So you know,
he doesn't get the
attention because of the,
no,
but you know,
other than that fade
or who's just violence,
every one of his fights was Zvi,
but PR intelligence and Anderson who
was just a wizard and understanding his
prime was the wizard of all wizards.
He would pull off things where you
just go get the fuck outta here.
What did I just say?
I like,
my favorite has always been Machida,
which he's great tennis.
Like there's something,
there's a beauty and grace
to the way he fights.
He reminds me of a matador.
He kind of looks like a matador and it's
got that kind of dark complexion and
dark hair.
And um,
I think Machita we spent too much of
his career at fighting at two oh five
degree.
He's too small for one 85 which is crazy.
Rockhold tore some rock holds a and
the and,
and you know,
uh,
who's Weidman is wave
is way more here too.
I just don't know anything about a fight.
Romero who's going to more
from to from Marilyn's Hue.
So he's taking the abuse
from these huge guys.
Yeah.
I just don't know how he fought
at two oh five for so long.
He would weigh in at two oh three
and like not cut any weight at all.
And then fight Tito Ortiz.
Who Weight two 30 or so.
This is a big giant dude.
I mean he fought Jago Silva was
huge at two oh five he taught.
Fought some big ass fucking dude,
but he fought very brilliantly.
But he's also,
he's in his late thirties I think
he's 37 or 38 and your body just,
you only have so many miles.
Yeah.
You know,
there's just,
you don't,
you don't get to change the tires.
You know,
getting these upgraded suspension.
He's taking some,
he's taking some abuse.
Well,
the Rockhold fight was the most abusive,
never to fun.
I didn't like that.
I mean Jon Jones choked him out and
when a guy choked you out like that,
that's not nearly as bad.
A shogun Kao down
essentially with one punch.
So those were like two big losses before.
But this Rockhold fight
was a fucking molestation.
It was a brutal,
no,
you shouldn't say that word.
I should say it was an assault.
That's what it was.
Bye Bye.
That's what I didn't
like about that fight.
By the end it was an assault on a
helpless victim and I feel like,
I feel like you were saying this too,
that that's a fight that should have
been ended probably on the stool.
I agree.
And you know his corner
should end up well,
they didn't even put his
mouthpiece in for the second round.
We didn't know about it.
He was saying something to the referee
and pointing in his mouth and I was
trying to figure out what he was
squaring off while they were in it.
When he was on the bottom,
can Rockhold was beating him up.
He pointed,
said to the referee something and pointed
to his mouth that he didn't have a
mouthpiece and the
referee didn't pick it up.
I mean,
you've got to check that the corners,
it's their ultimately their fault,
but the referee fucked up too.
You can't let a guy fight and get the
shit beat out of them with no mouthpiece
and,
well,
can we go back to that question about
the conflict you feel between being a
sports fan?
I'm a fan of this
massive fan of the sport.
No one's a bigger fan than you.
I'm a huge fan of the sport too,
but also that sense of,
ah,
you know,
dividedness you know,
that,
you know,
I mean,
here's how I feel about it.
It's like,
I feel like we're trapped in
this kind of devil's bargain.
You know,
we love the sport.
We admire the athletes
who've been worship a movie,
admire their,
their heroism,
that courage or skill,
stamina,
all of it.
Um,
and we love the drama of it.
We love the savagery of it.
We love the technique of it.
Um,
but at the same time we know
it costs these guys too much.
And I guess my question is,
is there any way out of
this devil's bargain?
Is there a way that we can make these
sports the sports safer than it is?
Well,
um,
I think you and I are both in agreement
with the gloves issue and you wrote
something about it and um,
I discussed it with Sam Harris.
I've discussed it with a bunch of people.
I feel like,
and
this would kind of be contradictory for
people who don't train in martial arts,
but I'll try to explain it,
uh,
visually for people who watch this,
which is a much smaller
percentage of the population.
If you look at someone's wrist,
um,
well your wrist,
when you hit things,
your risk tends to wiggle around.
It flexes and it,
it's very hard to keep your wrists
stiffed and hit things hard,
especially repeatedly when you're
bouncing your wrist off of elbows and
shoulders and,
and even foreheads you're eating tend
to break your hands much easier if you
don't have wraps.
And when you see a fighter in the UFC,
they have those gloves on.
Those gloves aren't really
protecting the other opponent,
the opponent of the person you're punching
nearly as much as they're protecting
the per person who's
punching the opponent.
But the big thing to me
is not just the gloves,
it's the raps.
Yeah.
Uh,
feel like when you tape
up your wrist to cast it,
yeah.
You can tape up your wrist
and you tape up your hands.
You make that thing hardest.
Fuck before I work out,
before I hit the bag or hit
the pads or anything like that,
I taped this fucking bitch down.
I go in between my knuckles,
I have uh,
these,
these pads that I put over my knuckles
and I tape over them and then I go
everything with the athletic tape and,
but at the end of it,
that fucking saying you could
slam things within and it just,
it's unnatural.
You get,
you have an unnatural
situation with your hands.
And when people say,
well it looks barbaric,
if you bare knuckle,
let me tell you something.
You would be way better off with me.
Bare knuckle punching in,
punching you,
then you would with me
kicking you with my Shin.
And that's totally legal.
Yeah.
We head kicks.
He'll like when you see like Terry Adam
versus Edson Barboza and Edson Barboza,
we'll kicks him in the head.
Yeah.
There is not a fucking punch that's
ever been thrown by a human being ever.
That as the kind of power
that a fucking wheel kick ass.
Your legs are especially
not that weight class.
And you'd have to have like the biggest,
most giant heavyweight boxer and still,
I don't think they could probably
punch as hard as a worldclass.
Kickboxer can throw a kick like that.
It was Kickstarter rare though.
I mean,
we're very rare.
One of the things that was interesting
to me is there's a paper out in some,
some,
some journal like the Canadian
Journal of Criminology,
not criminology and I'm sorry,
uh,
sports medicine or something like that.
Um,
went through all of
UFC fights over like a,
I'll say a decade.
Um,
and saw how they ended and when
it came to Chios Kaos and Tkos,
85% of them were from the hands.
Um,
so my feeling is,
you know,
again,
people have the wrong
idea about these gloves.
They really have the wrong idea.
They think it makes the sport safer,
uh,
and it,
and I think they can make it safer,
safer and it does make it
safer for the guys hands.
And the cost of that is
making an exponentially more
dangerous for that other
guy's brain.
You take those gloves off,
those guys cannot throw
their hands around like that.
If you glove it up,
tape it up,
you turn that fragile,
vulnerable fist.
Andrew,
a brutally dangerous cudgel and you could
throw around from all these different
angles.
You can throw Roy Nelson
Style overhand rights.
You can't throw that punch
with without gloves on.
You break your hand.
I mean instantly you kill
yourself cause that score,
he punched the score with a bare hand.
The scope punches you back.
Yeah.
If you hit someone,
if someone just ducks down and you
hit him with a straight punch on the
forehead,
it's like punching a wall.
So to me is that there was this tragedy
that happened and it happened in boxing
happen in boxing in 1867,
you know,
boxing was on the,
on the,
on the verge of getting outlawed
basically for being savage.
And they said,
okay,
we'll change the rules,
we'll add these different elements would
make it possible for referees to stop
fight and we'll put
pillows on the guys first.
So it was a well intended thing.
The well-intended thing,
we were well intended,
humanitarian gesture,
we'll make this the sport face safer by
put in these pills on these guys' hands.
And the UFC made exactly the same
mistake a 130 years later or something.
Uh,
they were on the verge
of getting outlawed.
They were having all kinds
of political problems.
And so they reformed.
They said,
well,
we're gonna,
we're gonna outlaw these really brutal
looking techniques and we are also going
to take away the prime symbol in the
public's mind of the savagery of cage
fighting,
which is bare fisted fighting.
It's even in our language when we say
we're going to take the gloves off,
right?
That means we're gonna resort to a
really primitive style of brutality.
Um,
and so,
uh,
so it was just,
it was a well-intended gesture
that backfired in a tragic way.
So people think that the,
the sort of savagery and
the damage and the danger,
the neurological danger,
especially of fighting is intrinsic
to the sport and unavoidable.
And it's not really true.
You could massively decrease the,
the danger of the neurological danger
of the sport just by taking off the
gloves.
Could you,
because a big percentage of
the blows that guys received,
they're receiving training and you're
very unlikely to train bare knuckle,
so you're going to steal.
You could still get tagged.
You're right.
There's also a,
an in paeds grappling in a lot of ways.
The gloves did.
Yeah,
of course.
Yeah.
They get in the way of a lot of chokes.
Um,
they get in the way their handles
and you can't get the men,
you close your neck up,
you can't get your gloves.
Some guys use them intelligently
to actually finish chokes.
I've seen Josh Thompson,
who's a very clever fellow.
He's uh,
done rear naked chokes where he reaches
under his own gloves and chokes guys and
foundation foundations
that it's quite sure,
but I'm not sure.
I can't reach inside
the other guys' glove.
You can't reach inside
the other gods glove.
I think you can grab your own glove
that you can grab your shorts,
you can grab your shorts
to defend yourself.
You can't grab your shorts
to finish a technique done.
I don't think,
I think if you had like
there is a position that you
could get where you could
have your arm wrapped around the
guy's neck and grab own shorts.
Yeah.
And,
and use your own shorts
to aid in the choke.
I'm wonder if you could do that.
I wonder if you could do it on offense.
I probably should know this
as soon as I do it for living.
But,
uh,
I know that you can use it defensively,
which is big with Kimora.
Yeah.
If a guy is going for a shoulder lock
and you've reached deep into your shorts
and you hold onto them,
it could be just enough to protect you
to keep you from forgetting tapped yet.
Um,
but I think,
you know,
if,
if you take the,
if you take the gloves off to,
uh,
I've already with some people about this,
they're like,
well,
if you did that and guys would
just throw more so more kicks,
they throw more needs,
they throw Morrell,
they would,
there'll be a little more
like bare knuckle Moyie Thai.
Yeah.
But I think,
you know,
I think paradoxically taken
the gloves off would also,
we can all the other weapons because
it's really hard to kick somebody in the
head lot if you're Donald's Serone well,
but,
but partly it's because they
have to respect as fis and
had a lot of respect for
his fists.
Yeah.
But it's also like you get close to him,
you get need like you get elbowed.
You know,
I I see,
I kind of disagree with that cause I think
it really just depends upon what kind
of skillset you get into MMA with.
If you get a guy who was a really good
kicker and you take away the gloves,
you just made his kicks better.
He does now.
He doesn't have to worry
nearly as much as that's true.
That's a good point.
I was thinking it,
the other guy,
uh,
the defender wouldn't be as vulnerable
to the kick because he doesn't,
he can,
he can look for the kick more cause he
didn't have to be aware of the other guys
fist.
But you're right,
the kicker doesn't have to worry about it.
It's,
that's a good point.
And one of the biggest problems with the
gloves is the fact that the fingers are
wide open and guys are poking each
other in the eye all the time.
It's a huge issue.
The UFC has tried to figure
out a way to do it to,
to mitigate it,
to have the same gloves but make
something where they curve more.
I think Bella tour came out with his
Everlast glove that I think has two,
two,
two opposing benefits.
Like it's more curved,
which I think is better to avoid some
of the posts like the old pride gloves.
Yes.
But also it's got more padding on the
top to protect the knuckles so they have
less broken hands.
But that means to me that
guys can punch harder.
So it's like you can,
you're more free to punch,
but you're less lucky to poke.
I will take that.
I'll take the less likely to get the
iPods because I think the I pokes or of,
that's a huge tragic issue for people
who aren't familiar with the sport.
Muay Thai,
the art of Thai boxing.
Um,
they,
they have a very specific
style of using the hands.
Well,
they'll like put the hands on the
forehead and they'll throw knees,
they'll put the hands up
and they'll throw kicks.
They'll put the hand dug.
They have a lot,
especially in different practitioners.
They have a lot of ways of using,
but when they're doing it
in the gym or in the ring,
they're usually wearing big boxing
gloves and the boxing gloves don't have
anything free to poke.
But fingers in MMA gloves,
the fingers are completely exposed.
And when guys utilize the same techniques,
try to keep a guy off them.
They,
they oftentimes up poking guys
right in the eyes and they
cause irreparable damage.
Like guys like Alan Belcher,
he's been out of the UFC for a long time.
He had knee surgery,
like significant eye surgery.
Michael Bisping had
significant eye surgery.
He has oil in his eye.
This thing does,
you look at one of his eyes,
he was different color.
It's like you don't see his pupil.
It's to protect his retina.
Yikes.
But he's such a fucking gangster.
That guy,
he's dealing,
they're thrown down with one bomb.
I think again though,
like when through these guys quit.
Well,
he still worldclass clearly,
you know,
I mean he still,
uh,
he just,
beat CB away and uh,
he showed he's still worldclass.
He's still one of the
best guys in the world.
The [inaudible] victory.
I mean,
that guy has a chair.
he really does have a chance till he
really has a dream and that dream is to be
a world champion.
And that mindset that he has that allows
him to fight with one fucked up by,
you know,
throughout,
and he has got something
wrong with his neck man.
He's always like banged up and
he's been fighting forever.
He's also been fighting clean and a lot
of his major losses are from guys who
weren't clean,
even if they weren't legally clean.
I mean,
even if what they were doing was legal,
like Henderson and v tour,
there's still weren't clean,
clean.
Chael Sonnen wasn't clean.
I mean all these guys were not clean them.
Right?
Yeah.
Almost everybody who beat him except
Rockhold Rockhold is just a fucking freak
of nature.
Yeah.
Freak of nature and a freak of training
with Cain Velasquez and Daniel Cormier
every fucking day,
you know,
he's just so God damn
good and long and strong,
I don't believe are big and strong.
He was watered.
Machida,
you know Javier Mendez was,
we were talking about it after the fight.
I was like,
God damn.
I was congratulating them.
I was like,
that was insane.
And they'll like,
you know what people
don't realize about him.
He's,
he's fucking strong.
And it's very rare that you get someone
who's real long but also really strong.
I don't know what the fuck he ways
when he actually gets in there,
but it ain't one 85 he looked young dude.
He dwarfs me.
I weighed 200 pounds and I mean,
I know I'm fat,
but when I stand next to him I'm like,
get the fuck out of here.
How are you?
One 85 he's six foot four and he looks
like he's about to 20 when he gets into
the cage.
It's insane.
I don't know how he makes that wait.
Yeah,
I don't either.
I don't have no idea how he
makes that fucking weight.
But he does it.
He does it and he can fight hard,
you know,
with the gloves because it's talking
about ways of making the sport safer.
That's,
that's another one.
I think that,
you know,
the,
the weight cutting issue is big.
How do you stop that?
It's impossible to stop probably,
but you know,
to me like the first guy to die and
the UFC is just as likely to die in the
sauna.
Well,
it's come very close.
There's been a few guys
backstage that fainted.
They blacked out and they put pulled
out of fights because they couldn't.
Yeah.
Hanan Barao was a big one.
That was a big one because
a rematch with Tj Dillashaw.
The fight was one of
the fights of the year.
One of the upsets of the,
the entire history of the UFC.
One of the biggest upsets,
a spectacular performance by Tj Dillashaw
Hanan Barao trains like a monster
ready for this comeback and then fall
passes out in the sauna or the bath
bathtub,
I guess,
and cracked his head off the wall
and they wouldn't let them find
me.
He knocked himself out trying
to get up out of the tub.
Yeah,
I felt like that and yoga today,
man.
I felt like I was going to black
out because you really now,
no,
but I mean it's like
an elevator everybody.
The heads house.
Yeah.
I do feel like I'm going to
pass out on the headstand.
I've felt like I've
realized what a bitch I am.
And uh,
I'm like grabbing my toes.
I'm like,
God,
I need a break.
It's too hot in here.
He's thinking about like what these guys
have to do in the fucking sauna to drop
20 pounds of water weight and that
they do it every three or four months.
Yeah,
I did.
I,
I only had one actual fight.
Um,
but I,
but I cut white twice
because the first fight I,
uh,
I showed up to and my opponent fearing
the legendary fisted prowess of English
professors.
He backed out.
He backed out the day of,
I got on the scale and everything.
I'm looking around,
my guy's not there and you know,
I was,
I was scared.
You know,
you're,
it's,
it's nerve racking to fight,
but after you've gone
through the weight cut,
man,
you don't want to not find
what was wrong with him.
He just didn't show up.
You're not small time amateur
shows and a lot of guys and say,
Hey,
you know this,
this seems like a good idea
a couple of months ago,
but you know as it got close,
he wasn't hurt or anything.
Just we had a guy from our gym that
would have panic attacks and there was a
couple of fights,
one fight where you almost couldn't,
he almost couldn't do it.
Like he was just falling apart
backstage and went up there and did it,
but he lost,
he got beat up pretty bad.
But then another fight where he just
pulled out backstage day of the fight,
getting prepped,
warming up,
wrapping the hands the whole day.
I can't do fucking here to do this.
How really,
you know it happens at the UFC.
It happens at the UFC
and people don't know.
You know,
there's guys that wind up fighting and
there's guys that are pretty highly
ranked.
I don't want to name any names,
but Shaw,
Brendan Schaub and I were actually having
a conversation about this the other
day about guys that were warming
up while he was back there.
And,
uh,
they would say to their coach,
I don't want to fucking do this anymore.
I'm done.
I don't want to do this anymore.
And like,
dude,
you got to fight in an hour.
But then they go out and they go out.
Yeah,
yeah.
You know?
Well,
you know,
I,
that's amazing to me because it's,
there's such,
you know,
part of the reason I fought finally
was because of the social pressure.
Like once you started off down this path,
um,
it becomes like this thing where like
you've told people you're going to do it
and everybody that Jim
knows you're going to do it.
And so one time I tried it,
I kind of tried to back out,
you know,
like months before my actual fight,
I said,
you know,
other writers have done this and you know,
I'm all her,
there's no reason to do it.
And I went in and told one of the guys
at the gym that I was kind of leaning
away from doing and he's like,
he's like,
well,
so,
so you're posting it now,
Huh?
And,
uh,
and then I told another guy,
he said,
well,
see your pussy now.
Uh Huh.
Um,
so everybody's kind of said that
and it becomes this huge pressure,
like to do it.
Um,
and I felt like this,
uh,
I felt more fear of failure and courage
than I did of the sort of whatever was
going to happen to me in the cage,
breaking my nose,
whatever.
I felt much
more fear that I would just find
a way to chicken out in the end.
I'd,
I'd get cold feet.
I'd refuse to climb the
steps and get in the cage.
Maybe I'd run for it in the cage.
Just sprint in circles around the outside,
jumped over the fence,
run for home.
You know,
I honestly thought that could happen,
you know,
so I can,
so I can relate.
It's kind of amazing that they got backed
out backstage because there's so much
at that point.
Your whole,
the whole warrior society
sees you doing it,
you know what I mean?
The big blow.
Yeah.
You know,
sometimes guys are injured and then
they get there and they realize like,
I can't fuck,
I can't do it.
I can't move my leg.
Right.
Yeah.
There's a lot of guys who fight.
That's another thing.
The guys would fight in
the UFC that are fucked up.
They're really injured by
the time they get in there.
I know guys who have hid a torn ACL tear.
Their ACL is,
we're completely blown out and
they really had no stability.
Like they would,
uh,
they would try to move one way or another
and then knee would just give right
out.
And there's a mean,
there's gotta be nothing more terrifying
than being in the octagon and competing
against some highly trained,
well prepared killer.
And you can't even move right?
If you,
if you juke left or right,
your legs going to go boink if
you blown out a knee before,
do you know that?
No,
I've never done that.
It's still at worst.
It's not the worst.
Worst is there's obviously way worse,
but um,
it's a bad feeling because you
just know it's going to give out.
You don't know when and you
go to move left or move.
Right.
And it just goes boing.
And ACL is a spare apparent,
uh,
particularly rather because a,
that's the big one that goes down the
center of the knee that keeps it stable
moving forward and it,
uh,
it can blow out on a lot
of people that blows out.
It's like one of the more
common knee injuries.
Dominick Cruz of course is famously
going through his second one.
Is third a third operation?
A second knee though.
Just fucking crazy.
That's awful.
Yeah.
It's real common though.
George Saint Pierre got
both his knees done.
One of them blew out after his career
was over or after he stepped down for a
little bit.
Um,
you know,
[inaudible] has had her ACL done.
Lot of fighters have other ACL done.
It's probably one of the most common
injuries that a fighters have in UFC.
Any sport,
really.
Acl,
it seems soccer.
Apparently it's the most
common football at time.
Beth football at the time,
you have the human bodies just fucking,
it's designed to get you to like age
26 and by the end you're almost dead.
Yeah.
Saber Tooth Tigers are looking
for you to show up limping.
That's true.
It's just shit design man.
Yeah.
Well it's a shit design for playing NFL
football for a punching people in the
head is a shit shit design
for fighting for a living.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
I mean,
it's not made for that.
No.
You know,
that's,
that's a bit much.
Well,
when you see an NFL player and a,
I've only met a few of them,
but when you meet them it's like fucking,
they were like giants
from game of Thrones.
That's a real person.
Jesus fucking Christ.
I remember one time I
was in Phoenix and uh,
we,
we had,
uh,
just got done with the show.
We did a comedy show at the Tempe Improv
and then we went to a bar and when we
went to a bar,
there was this big line of people that
we're trying to get to this place.
We're meeting our friend there and one
of these guys was an NFL player and he
just sort,
it was like a man amongst children whose
just like moving through this crowd.
He was about six foot seven and he was
probably 350 pounds and he was so fucking
big.
And like you looked at him and
just go where you feel like a girl.
Do you feel like a girl?
I was.
I have a friend like that,
you know,
if he'd played a big time
college football and you're six,
seven 200 high,
two hundreds and I'd stand up with
them at the bar and it was like,
and I'd be looking at his tits,
you know,
and I'd be like,
this is how you had talked to him.
I'm like,
this is what it feels like for women.
Yeah.
All the time.
They're looking up over this
guy that can just do this,
except they get turned on by
them and they want to fuck them.
That's true.
That's different.
I hope you didn't get turned out well.
No.
If you did,
that's fine.
But,
um,
but it's more of a worrisome,
like is he going to try to fuck me because
I hope it doesn't cause I'll have no
choice.
Yeah,
there's no,
there's no equality when it
comes to physical attributes.
There's certain people that were just
given a way better genetic roll the dice
when it comes.
I mean,
that's why we have weight classes.
It's why mighty mouse can never fight
Jon Jones is now the argument can take
place.
So as to who's better pound for pound?
John are mighty mouse and there's
a lot of arguments both ways,
but as far as like what
would happen if they fight,
there's no argument.
There's no,
no argument at all.
I mean,
Jon Jones is a talented enough where he
probably could fight and beat most of
the heavyweights,
if not all the heavyweights.
I think he,
yeah.
Yeah.
You know,
this whole thing with him is so tragic.
It's so tragic and you know,
more tragic for the woman
he hit with his car.
But so tragic for him because you know,
I don't know him well enough to know
like where his mind's at or who he's
talking to and you,
you hear all these bad things like the
people that he's hanging out with and the
people that he surrounds himself with.
You here,
some of them from his coaches.
So there's gotta be some
village and truth to it.
But for every guy like that,
that's super fucking talented,
it seems like it's so
hard to stay on track.
It's like Mike Tyson had custom motto,
you know,
and custom motto was not
just a great trainer,
but it was also a great mental coach.
Like he had instilled lessons in Mike
Tyson about fire and fear and all the,
all the different aspects of competition
that are going to arise and how the
hero and the coward feel the same thing.
It's just the hero
reacts to it differently.
And then just the more
you prepare your body,
the less,
not fear,
but the less confusion you have
when you get into that ring,
the less doubt you have,
the less,
the more clarity you have.
You're 100% confident and you're
conditioning your 100% confident in your
training.
There will be certain
fear but you can mitigate some of that.
And all this was custom model just was
a genius with Tyson plus he was like a
father figure.
It was like a perfect example.
But Jon Jones had a father,
the father middle class.
I've still does.
You know he still does,
but what I'm saying is a coach you need,
you don't need that just in a father.
I mean his father,
does he have that out in Albuquerque with,
with uh,
Jackson?
I think he does to a certain extent,
but Jon Jones is so fucking good.
The guys who trained with him,
the guys who talk,
like if you talk to people you'll like,
he's so good.
He's so much better than
everybody else in the gym.
He's so much better than it.
I mean,
when you saw him grab a hold of Daniel
Cormier and wrestle Carme 80 the ground,
the first round,
he'll like,
listen,
this is another fucking level
shit you're dealing with.
You're dealing with like
another level of greatness.
Another level of ability and when you,
you know,
you see a guy like that get involved
and I mean the cocaine thing,
man,
that didn't bother me that much.
It's like it's always doing coke.
Three weeks out.
He's a bad motherfucker.
He wants a party,
you know?
That's how I look at it.
You know why?
Because I'm not,
I'm,
I don't look at this as like,
no,
I don't have any cure.
A 10 don't know me.
She's like,
Hey,
let's have fun.
What would I get upset if he had a drink?
Three you know,
three months out.
No.
So,
or three weeks out or whether,
how many weeks was it?
How many weeks was it
before the fight about that?
It sounds right.
Four or five weeks.
I don't know it was,
but what I could get mad if he had a beer.
Donald Cerrone drinks Budweiser up until
the fucking week of his weight cut.
That's a fact.
And he doesn't just drink a little,
he drinks a lot.
What's worse for you?
Alcohol or cocaine?
Well,
I don't know how much John was doing,
but a little line here and there is
probably not as bad as the amount of
Budweiser that Donald socks down.
That's true.
I mean,
I don't fucking know man.
I don't know.
I think part of the issue that people
have with a guy like John who's just so
Uber talented and he's so young
and all these things come handy,
Tammy said,
oh,
just come so,
so easy to him is that when a guy like
that professors to be like very moral and
you know,
very religious and then you see all
this craziness like tested positive for
cocaine and the drunk
driving crash into a tree,
which strippers in his car.
It's like,
yeah,
clearly he likes to have fun,
you know,
and there's another wrong with that.
Nothing wrong at all.
It's in part of his dumb or
the drill dumb about it though,
you know,
so really party.
But uh,
it could be that nobody can control.
I mean,
it's also like when you're,
that guy came good.
You don't want to listen to anybody,
you know,
you're the fucking man.
Tons of guys in the UFC and other
sports who keep it together.
You know,
George St Pierre was awesome.
He was very disciplined.
You know,
the still a template together,
which fucked up too.
Like George totally underestimated.
Matt Serra totally underestimated.
Matt Serra got in there with him
and got crushed and that's just you.
You got to dot your i's
and cross your t's all day,
every day.
You can't take anyone lightly.
And we've,
I've seen that many times where guys
were way favored over their opponent,
but they took it lightly because they
were favorite and their opponent was
terrified because they were the underdog.
So they train like a demon and the other
guy's slacked off and went in there
with a false sense of confidence and also,
uh,
minimize sense of danger.
Like nobody likes that fucking feeling,
man.
You and you went through it,
right?
Yeah.
That feeling of being in the locker room,
you're like,
ah,
gluttonous is over.
I'll get me out there.
When I stopped competing,
there was the one thing
that I appreciated the most.
Like I didn't have to feel
like I was always scared.
Yeah.
I was always like,
we're waiting for the next fight.
You know,
the,
the book,
uh,
the book is,
I say it's about the dual,
the dual,
you know,
the pistols at dawn.
Broadly defined,
Sorta,
Sorta Mano on keep that actually.
Thank you.
I still owe money on my face on it.
Think about me when you get your coffee.
That's great man.
You're pretty keen on that thing.
I already think about Q,
I drink my coffee.
Um,
but you know,
I sort of thought about
Mano a Mano conflict of,
of,
of various kinds and uh,
you know,
so an MMA fight or any kind
of combat sport fights,
kind of a dual,
set it up in advance.
You know,
you have seconds who negotiate for you
work your corner and all that stuff and
you know,
weeks out,
months out,
even you even longer that you're going
to be in a car crash at such and such a
time,
you know,
and it weighs on you,
weighs on you so heavy.
Um,
whereas,
you know,
if you were to walk out in the parking
lot right now and some guy picked a fight
with you that be bad,
but it wouldn't,
you wouldn't have the same kind of fear
and anxiety that the buildup to it.
So yeah,
I was glad to get that out of my life.
Uh,
because I had,
I looked at that for a long time because
it took me a long time to get a fight
to me in a long time because I was old
and state commission makes it pretty hard
for older fighters to,
to,
to allow a certain match up in fights,
kept calling through or somebody would
not show up or I would get hurt or that
guy,
we get hurt.
And so I live with that sense that the
fight was right around the corner for
maybe six months.
Did fuck with your sleep?
Oh,
everything.
Yeah.
I just lived in,
I lived with his mild sense of anxiety
punctuated by these stabs of terror,
you know what I mean?
And that's when I would start
negotiating with myself saying to myself,
you know,
other writers have done this before,
what the hell?
What's,
what's the point of this?
There's no,
there's no point in actually fighting,
you know,
you can,
you can train it,
the gym,
you can do a lot of stuff.
There's no point in actually having a,
the actual fight as well.
I was glad to get that out of the way
and I was glad to get out of the weight
management because that was
the other hard thing about it.
So for those six months,
I was staying at a very uh,
low way.
What were you trying to weigh in at?
Well,
I started the project
and close to 200 pounds.
I was heavier,
uh,
kind of fat.
Um,
and uh,
and then I,
you know,
so like if I want 85,
I could fight at two oh five,
you know,
bulk up and quite the huge guys.
Um,
uh,
by decided to fight,
I'll win all the way down to one 70.
Um,
and so I cut down to where I
was walking around like one 80.
Cause at the amateurs you don't have 24,
30 hours,
whatever,
whatever it is to rehydrate.
How much do you have?
Uh,
we weighed in like a 10
o'clock in the morning for a,
for a fight.
Fights.
It started at seven that day.
Yeah.
Whoa,
that's dangerous.
Yeah.
People don't cut a lot of weight,
so I kinda like,
should you cut?
Uh,
I started,
I started cutting like the week of
like bit starving myself and mild
dehydration.
Um,
and by the time,
by like the night before my fight,
I was like one 76,
I think.
And then I got up in the
morning and sweated it all out.
So you sweat out six pounds,
uh,
for,
I've actually overdid it.
I kind of screwed up because
I didn't have a scale.
I had no idea how much I
was actually sweating down.
Well,
I had a scale way.
You have no idea how you cut weight
and then fought the same day.
That's illegal in most places.
Again,
how are they going to know,
you know?
Well,
you get to know,
did you rehydrate?
Oh yeah.
I know I was.
I was at one 68.5 at Wingham,
so I actually lost like seven pounds
that morning or seven and a half pounds.
And then,
um,
and then I just,
well no ivs.
No,
no,
no.
I didn't.
No,
I don't.
I don't know.
I wasn't doing a scientific way co,
you know,
I mean you're a smart guy.
Yeah.
But I'd read up on it,
but I didn't know how,
how would I get a guy to give me an
idea how to talk to a fucking doctor.
You went through all this preparation
and didn't prepare enough to find a
doctor.
Yeah.
Nivea drip.
It's just water.
It's nothing unethical about it.
Yeah,
we'll do it when you're demeaning.
Treat it.
That does not appear to be the culture of,
of,
of the,
of the MMA world that I was moving in.
I don't mean,
I don't know the guys were getting ivs,
but they're crazy.
If they're not cutting weight,
you should get an ivy.
I still put every pound of
those six pounds back on by,
by the time the fight give,
you know,
the issue's not putting the water back on.
It's getting the water in your brain.
Yeah,
that's the real issue.
All of the more significant deaths,
brain damage,
all the big issues and boxing,
almost all of them up to like it
except for a few isolated events,
which were horrible beatings,
which is why I think Eric
Perez was involved in one.
Is it Eric Perez?
Heavyweight?
I was involved in some horrible beating
of this Russian guy and that guy
suffered some pretty
significant brain damage,
which is a heavyweight belt,
which is very rare.
It's usually little guys.
It's usually the people that cut weight.
It's usually the people that cut weight,
the duck Ku Kim's and yeah,
I mean that's one of the fights where
they made the way in the day before the
fight.
They changed it after that fight.
They also change it from 15 rounds
to 12 rounds because you know,
people were realizing like,
hey man,
like this is fucking dangerous.
Losing all this weight.
You dehydrate your actual brain,
you make yourself more susceptible
to brain trauma and bleeding.
Yeah,
Gerald Mcclellan.
So and other one was a notoriously huge
guy would cut a tremendous amount of
weight to get down.
I think he's fighting at one 75
the one 75 one 68 I forget what,
what he fought at,
but Gerald cut a tremendous
amount of weight,
got down,
fought Nigel Benn and,
and had like a,
he was,
he was bleeding inside the octagon
like or inside the ring rather.
He had a,
an episode where he like had
a stroke inside the ring.
Like in the middle of his fight he had
to take a knee and then just quit and
realized something was way wrong.
And people like that can't,
I can't believe he quit and he
collapsed in his corner and you know,
the rest is history.
He's all fucked up now.
And if you went back to the day,
if you ever watched that guy fight,
you've ever see Gerald Mcclellan
fight like back in the day?
Well,
he was a terrifying fighter and the big
show down was always going to be him and
Roy Jones jr that's what
everybody was thinking.
Like one day,
him and Roy Jones Jr going to throw down.
Gerald McClellan was fucking killer.
He was a killer.
But he fought Nigel Benn and
Nigel band was just tough as shit.
And they went to war and Gerald
had them all but knocked out,
had them knocked out of the ring,
like you went through the ring,
got back into the ring,
got back.
But just nodule ban would not quit.
And there was a period in the fight
somewhere where they collided heads.
And that was one of the big
ones mean Nigel definitely land.
It's a big punches on them,
but they collided heads and you
could tell like after the head,
but like he was all fucking
woozy and whacked out and then,
you know,
he had to take a knee
and then it was over.
And he's,
he's blind now.
I think he can't hear,
he can't move.
He's all fucked up and it's
all just from brain bleeding.
So it's,
it's a real issue.
The dehydration issues are real issue.
Yeah.
And you said,
you know,
earlier on you said,
how do you stop it?
And I think it,
I think it is one of those things,
it's really,
really hard to stop because you know,
as you've talked about on the show,
any kind of a new measure you set up,
there's a way to beat it.
There's a way,
there's still going to be a cutting way.
I think amateur wrestling
has dealt with this,
a little kits,
um,
by body fat percentages of
things or maybe hydration,
uh,
measurements.
Like you can measure how much
a hydration there they haven't.
So you can tell when the kid is
cutting weight through dehydration.
Right?
I'm not sure if that will be possible to,
to measure hydration levels
and that might be one way to,
to deal with it.
But,
but I,
but I agree with you.
That one's a hard one to fix.
That's why I keep going
back to the gloves.
I'm obsessed with the gloves things.
Right.
Right now we use those test
with them for a good reason.
Why?
I mean if you agree on this,
after all your study,
after all these years,
um,
and I agree on it,
why isn't,
why didn't,
why do you think it's not a happening?
Cause it's incredibly hard to change.
Once
these commissions have these rules
and regulations in pray in place,
they're very difficult to change.
Once they're established,
they're insanely difficult
change.
I think there's a policy
would be against it or for it.
The USC probably would be against it
in the current state.
I mean,
even if they listened to me,
they rationalize like,
wow,
you got some good points.
And then there would be all but bubble
blow we can't because blah blah blah over
the Bubba bubby,
uh,
well first of all,
people would think it's barbaric.
So the public perception,
public perception,
uh,
more cuts,
which is probably true,
probably a lot more cuts from knuckles.
Knuckles were hand injuries in first and
much more hand until the shorter hours,
shorter careers.
You would shorten your careers.
I mean,
there's certain guys that have had
like significant head injuries.
One of the reasons why when you see Vitor
Belfort throw all these kicks recently
because his hands,
her hands had been broken
seven fucking times.
He's said seven injuries,
a seven surgeries rather.
I think my,
my uh,
I think the major obstacle to it,
if you,
if you thought it all through the major
obstacle to it would be the upside of
this is it would be a lot
less neurological damage.
The downside to it would be there'd be
a lot less neurological damage and be a
lot fewer knockouts.
Um,
there'd be a lot less heavy,
uh,
you know,
the barrages of heavy punches.
Um,
and they'd have to change their,
their,
their repertoire of punches.
He had to go back towards the bare
knuckle style style of punching a much,
much,
much more straight punches,
uh,
trying to throw punches into the fleshy
part of the face that you're throwing up
with more control,
many more punches to the padded torso
using these two knuckles as well,
using the front two knuckles.
Oh,
in traditional,
she read a bare knuckle
boxing book and you know,
they go back to the techniques of
how it was done back then and they,
they're not giving that to the,
to knuckle things would,
would,
I always learned to,
that's a boxer's teach
what martial artists teach.
Uh,
their,
their thing and it makes some sense.
They're saying this is a surface,
you turn it that way so
you have more surface area.
So you're not screaming,
you're not putting so much damage here.
And you say,
I've heard people say,
you know,
you're in alignment there,
but you're kind of also
an alignment there.
That's not so bad either.
Well,
the real issue is to write
the bare knuckle boxing.
What you're saying is they
would throw it perpendicular.
Yeah.
Instead of parallel with the ground throw,
throw a perpendicular punch into a boxing,
uh,
until heavy bag and
see what it feels like.
And you don't get as much power,
not nearly as much power.
And it's designed to be that way
because if you throw us out of the hands
because your fist will
just explode on contact.
Yeah.
Some people wouldn't
have any problem with it.
Some people would like big giant hands
like Brock Lesnar hands or Shane car when
hands,
those guys probably wouldn't
have nearly as much problem.
But if you can go back to the old UFC and
you see when guys fought bare knuckle,
you've very rarely saw like
blistering combinations.
Like you'll see like a
guy like [inaudible],
you know barrages of punches.
He very rarely see those
cause he's just Kinda can't,
you kind of can't do those
without breaking your hand.
And they did break their hands a lot.
So you know,
I started,
I thought that article I
wrote with a retrospective on,
remember this fight,
one of the greatest fights in the UFC,
a hackney versus Yarber all shore.
He bitch slapped him.
You know [inaudible] was like a
600 pound sumo wrestler who's six,
eight Agnes probably to 15 maybe he was,
he weighed in at 200 200 karate guy.
And this was the early wild west
days of the USC where they like,
what will happen?
We don't know.
Let's,
let's see what happens.
What happens when,
you know,
a normal size man fights
a giant and you know,
long story short,
a hackney hits him in the head,
uh,
41 straight times.
I counted with his right
hand and at some point,
you know,
he gets a yard boiled turtled up on the
ground and he's hitting him from the
back
and he's,
he's hooking him from behind.
He's coming in the back of the skull.
You could do that back then.
He's raising his hand up high,
like a black Jack and he's like camera
focusing on one side and then hammer fist
and it on the other and he
just screwed up his hand,
uh,
terribly.
Um,
so,
you know,
he walks,
Yarbrough walks out of the rings,
he's fine,
he tapped out verbally,
but he walked out of the ring
looking no worse for wear.
Those punches weren't all that effective.
Um,
how can he goes out of the ring looking
at his fist and it's swelling up and
it's bleeding.
And that was the end for him.
He didn't get to go to the next
round because he had broken his hand.
And so,
you know,
to me it was,
it's this great illustration of what
would have happened if hackney had a glove
on.
He would have beaten them to sleep.
Maybe.
Probably big head Yarbrough's in
Hackney is a strong guy and he
threw 41 punches at his brain,
you know,
and how can it was put in,
your role was putting up no defense.
He weighed 600 pounds.
He couldn't get up.
Yeah.
He was stuck there on the ground.
He's just laying there and getting
punched in the head over and over and over
again.
Yeah.
He's probably in the worst shape of
any guy who ever fought in the UFC.
Yeah.
Maybe Aki.
Bono hoists crazy.
Yeah.
And in retrospect it looked incredibly
barbaric because you're like,
that guy should never have been in cage.
But people didn't know back then.
Well,
he was a giant sumo champion.
He was giant.
He was someone athletic,
you know,
he did some kind of athletic
things in that Matt moved.
Yeah.
He moved like you did.
He did a,
that was enough.
Yeah,
it was 600 pounds.
He's chasing like a giant.
He's got his arms out.
It's like Frankenstein chasing him down.
But you know,
he,
he literally through a
hackney through the cage,
you know,
threw him out of the
cage and down the stairs,
you know,
broke,
broke the,
broke the gate.
What would hackney did was hit him with
an open palm and I think that was the
first knockdown as think
if he stuck with that,
he probably wouldn't have broken his hand,
which is kind of amazing.
But for whatever reason you can,
you can hit things really hard like
that with the palm of your hand.
And partly because you can
hit very hard that way.
Well,
you can't do it if you hit the,
it's,
it's the same thing.
And like you can,
if you're not turning it over,
was he ever watch boss route
and fight and pancreas?
That's true.
Boss route and figured out how to do it.
Yeah.
I mean he was the first guy that really
figured out pancreas was organization.
Yeah.
Pancreas was an organization for folks
who don't know in Japan and they didn't
allow gloves and they also
didn't allow punches to the face.
You could kick the guy to the face,
but you were wearing wrestling shoes.
And then on top of those wrestling
shoes you had these big fat thin,
uh,
this big fat Shin and instep pad.
So there's this big padded up Shin thing
and then you had nothing on your hands.
So the guys would get a slap at each
other and try to kick each other.
And that was the rule to right.
You couldn't throw clothes hand,
I could not throw a closed hands,
but you could throw a
closed hands to the body.
But Bas Rutten who was a Dutch kickboxer
and had his fucking power explosion
style,
he was the first guy that figured out
if you just pull your hand way back,
he throw that bitch just like a punch.
And he would upper cut guys and
hook guys and he would beat,
like when he fought food knocky he beat
the fucking shit out of him and he beat
him like a guy who's throwing punches.
I mean he would come at
you with his hands pulled back like that.
And instead of doing what
everybody else was doing,
which just kind of throw these wild
bitch slaps bas Rutten was throwing them
straight down the pipe and somehow or
another he had stretched his hand out.
Well he could pull his hand way back.
So he was just palming your
fucking nose in your brain.
He was nasty.
He was the first guy to
figure out like you could,
you could,
there's a different approach you can
take to this who's also one of the first
real strikers.
Uh,
you got to see the difference when
he kicked guys that fucking whack.
You feel it in their arms.
You know,
it's like one of the beautiful things
about watching the UFC since 93 all the
way up to 2015 where we are today is,
uh,
the evolution of the understanding of
the techniques of what's effective in
certain positions.
The distances and those guys like boss
route and were critical for establishing
that stuff.
Know there's real pioneers.
Fucking nobody before him and pancreas,
they were fighting like that.
There's nobody,
he came along with big power in his
kicks and ridiculous punching power.
And figured out how to
do it with the palm,
you know,
and then you see him fight in the UFC
when he could use punches before his body
started failing him.
Like he's had some
significant neck injuries.
And to the point where he has
significant atrophy of one of his arms,
one of his arms,
he calls baby arm.
Oh,
it's like,
yeah,
he's,
he's had it fixed and had some stem cell
stuff done and some operations and as
disks fuse in his neck.
And that stuff is a cost to this man.
Fuck gatherers.
But my point is you watched
him fight against Chokey,
she'll Kosha Co TK,
uh,
in the UFC when he won the
heavyweight title and you know,
he was throwing fucking
brutal combinations and his
neck was so fucked up before
that fight.
He couldn't even wrestle.
He fought most of that fight.
And we're trained most of that fight,
just kickboxing because
his neck was so fucked up.
But you know,
I remember him wearing a red
boots and a Pancrase probably.
We're a bunch of different boots,
you know.
I bet.
But you could kick with the boots.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You have,
you had these wrestling
shoes on with these,
uh,
Shannon step cards over the
top of the wrestling shoes.
I thought he had like,
like big patent,
leather red,
no excuse,
miss misremembering.
And they were wrestling shoes.
Yeah,
they were wrestling shoes.
Pancrase had like an outfit that they
would make you where you would wear like
those little skivvies and you weren't
wearing like those MMA shorts the guys
wear today.
Everybody wore like this little speedos.
Yeah.
Little grape smugglers.
And you know,
it's,
it's like an important time
historically to watch those fights,
to say the difference between the way
they fought then and the way they fight
now.
It's,
um,
there's still room to grow.
But the problem is you
have athletic commissions,
you have bureaucracy,
and you also have,
look,
I love the UFC.
I love working for the UFC.
It's been an honor to work
for them all these years,
but they're going to have a certain amount
of stagnation when you have one group
in one organization that's so
dominant over the other ones.
I disagree that it's a
monopoly because Viacom
owns Bella tour and Viacom has
untold fucking billions of dollars.
They have an entire channel
they can promote it on the,
I mean,
Spike TV has an entire Friday night
lineup that's dedicated to combat sports,
boxing,
glory,
kickboxing mean.
There's plenty of eyes on spike I,
and they're also getting
guys from the UFC now.
Like they have Phil Davis
just sign with them.
Well yeah,
it's sort of the senior
league for the UFC.
And there's also,
they picked up this
wrestler of the sky who,
uh,
helped Chris Weidman prepare
for one of his recent fights.
They've,
they've,
they're starting to get like these big
time names guys that are coming up.
And a lot of that is also
because of the Reebok deal.
The UFC has a Reebok deal that doesn't
allow them to get their own sponsors.
They have to use the Reebok sponsorships.
So some guys are shying away
from it because of that.
So like the concept of a monopoly,
I just don't think it's fair.
I know I don't agree that it's a monopoly.
I think they're better
than the rest of them.
There's better competition.
They're better organized.
I think the production is better.
The people that direct it
and produce it or better,
they're just the best at what they do
because they've been doing it a long time.
But in having that like that,
there's a certain amount of stagnation
because if someone came along and had a
bare knuckle UFC style,
um,
you know,
mixed martial arts event where they
fought not in a cage but in a basketball
sized Matt,
you know,
like he like if you have
arena for basketball,
you have this big gigantic space
that you have a wooden floors,
parquet floor on.
How about do something like
that with the mats and have,
have mixed martial arts and
when they go out of bounds,
you bring them right back to center again.
You have them Duke it out again.
Cause I cause the fence,
the fence is starting.
The fence is interesting
but it hurts visually.
You can't see that good me,
I can't see that good and have the best
fucking seat in the house for the UFC.
I'm touching the floor
that they're fighting,
literally touching the floor.
I see you looking at the
monitor all the time.
Sometimes I have to sometimes when,
when fighters like to the left or to the
right and the backs like they're like
up against the cage.
I have to look at the Monitor.
Otherwise I don't know what's going.
I don't know if you've ever looked at
the crowd and we're all looking at the
monitor to a lot of times.
I mean it's amazing to me.
People pay for this good
seats and everybody's looking
up at the screen because
the,
it just shows better up there.
Less so with boxing,
if you watched boxing,
people were looking at the ring most of
the time it's because of the ropes or
the way someone,
exactly.
In that sense,
pride had the better idea
when it came to that,
but um,
it was too hard,
too easy to go flying through the ropes
here they had a bunch of Japanese dudes
outside that we were like ready to press,
keep you from going out.
And they had guys like would
knock in your hand off the ropes.
It was that it was that.
It was also like a thought.
It was Paulo Filio.
I think someone used the ropes
want to catch a guy in an arm bar.
Like you had the guy,
like they were trapped inside the ropes
and the guy's arm was trapped in the
rope.
I was getting arm barred
and I was realizing like,
Whoa,
like he just used the rope
to get that submission.
This is kind of fucked.
Like the rope came into play.
It's almost like what
tank Abbott's submitted.
Steve Genom,
he had his knee to his head and he grabbed
the fence and he was holding onto the
fence and polling and
smashing them in the face.
You know that using the cage back then
like you can't grab the cage just like
you can't grab the ropes and pride,
but it did come into play too often.
It comes into play still too much too.
It'd be interesting.
I'd like that because there's so much of
the action now is pushed up against the
fence.
I think if a guy grabs a fence,
immediate one point deduction,
immediate,
immediate one point.
The problem is it's so reflexive.
It doesn't guys,
most guys don't mean to do.
It's,
it's like,
you know,
some guys do,
some guys fucking grabbed that bitch,
they grab it.
They should know.
You should know.
That's true.
I mean,
you gotta know,
you gotta fucking know.
And there's a big difference between a
guy grabbing the fence when you're trying
to take him down and then being able to
stand up and then kicks you in the head
and a guy not grabbing the fans and you
take him down and you dominate him for
the rest of the round.
And there's certainly could
never penalized on it.
No.
Well,
they get warnings.
They should get an immediate
one point deduction.
Same thing for obvious Ipos and
immediate one point deduction.
And Dana has had this,
Dana White said this,
that might be the only way to stop.
I pokes to give them an immediate one
point deduction and I think that might,
it might work.
I think there's gotta be a way
to cover the tips of the fingers.
I mean I don't,
I don't necessarily think that
these Bruce Lee style gloves,
that's what I was thinking were invented
in enter the dragon or the only way to
do it.
Yeah.
Well we haven't met
our gym like some guys.
Where are those?
The Bruce Lee style gloves.
Yeah,
those are cool.
But what I'm saying is something to cover
the tips of the fingers because as a
Jujitsu guy,
like if I had like,
um,
say like,
you know those Everlast bag gloves,
you know those style they'd come over the
tips like those aren't really going to
impede my grappling that much because
I don't do this and I don't do this.
You know,
you never,
you never know what I'm saying.
I'm,
I'm showing something to honestly the
people who were listening but interlacing
your fingers,
you don't interlace your fingers.
You grab and like an escrip or you grab
and a gable grip and these grips that
you would do most of the really strong
grips don't ever involve your fingers
sliding into the grooves and each
other of the opposing fingers.
Huh.
But I feel like something like that
maybe could work where the tips of the
fingers were covered up and it wouldn't,
wouldn't affect you as
much if I poke somebody.
Um,
it was,
but what kind of like going
into a dark territory here,
um,
d having this experience and I wanted
to get back to your peers because we
didn't,
I don't think we really completely,
uh,
we kind of got off track with that.
Having these people stand
outside and watch you do this.
Was there,
uh,
the,
the reaction very,
or was it pretty,
pretty uniform or was there an extremes
on both ends where people like,
what the fuck are you doing?
And other people were like,
I want to be like you.
Ah,
I don't know if anybody was
saying I want to be like you.
I doubt that.
Uh,
but,
um,
I don't know what was said behind my back,
you know,
here we got Charles Dylan,
Jesus,
you know,
can you believe this?
Uh,
what a,
what a monster.
Um,
for the most part,
people were cool about it.
You know,
it's,
uh,
you know,
to my nail,
you,
they knew me,
knew me,
and I knew,
you know,
uh,
and I made light of it,
you know,
to me it was always,
I always,
you know,
played it off in a sort
of a humorous way as a,
you know,
basically me being fed to the lions,
right?
So,
but again,
the bigger for the bigger problem
is in the wider professional.
People don't know me and you know,
when,
so when those sort of people
get Ahold of the book,
uh,
I hope they read it,
you know,
because the book is,
uh,
it's not really even
about mixed more shorts,
you know,
it's about using mixed martial arts as
this bridge into big questions about
human behavior,
especially who in male behavior and the
nature of masculinity and all the dumb
stuff we get up to.
And it's one of the
reasons I thought of you,
um,
as I was writing the book actually,
you know,
I,
a lot of people write a book and they
don't have anybody in mind for it to have
like a,
uh,
a vague nebulous sense of who
the readers are going to be.
I never works for me.
I always have to think
of an actual person,
you know,
who's going to read this book.
Like who would be the ideal reader for me.
And for me it was you,
I thought you a lot when
I was reading this book,
uh,
as a person,
like who would be interested
in this subject matter,
uh,
charitable and generous about it
because these are things that uh,
you've,
you wonder about too and also sort of
meshes with not only your interest in
fighting,
but your whole interest in human
behavior and especially you're basically
evolutionary a outlook on
human life and human behavior.
That's what the book is really about.
It's sort of an
evolutionary exploration of,
of,
of the,
of the basis of,
of masculinity and manhood.
That's a,
that's a very interesting
way of approaching it
because I think that's one of
the issues that people have when it comes
to the idea of mixed martial arts or
the idea of any sort of combat sport is
that in embracing that and supporting it
or in even just pursuing
it somehow or another,
we're doing a disservice to the idea of
a cultural evolution that we kind of all
agree is going on.
If you compare society and human beings
and our behavior today with what we know
about several thousands of years ago,
we know that we're in a far safer time,
far more civil time,
uh,
for the most part in
most places of the world.
Obviously there's exceptions,
but overwhelmingly the people that are
communicating now we're communicating
about w we have an understanding
about what we would call,
you know,
what they,
the super progressive to
call toxic masculinity.
Man,
you know,
which,
and part of me,
part of me understands
where they're coming from.
And part of me also thinks that
where they're coming with their,
their kind of copping
out and they're denying,
there's still denying certain aspects
of their own life and their own
masculinity that maybe they,
uh,
they feel are weak and maybe they feel
like they can't compete in these areas
and they feel intimidated.
So they want to demean them.
And I don't think that's right either.
You know,
like there's some,
well,
masculinity is complex,
you know,
and it is there,
there are things about it.
So it's femininity,
right?
I mean,
was being a human being
a human is a complex,
uh,
sort of thing.
And there are,
there is something,
there is a case to be made
that masculinity run a muck
is the great problem of
history.
Oh,
no doubt that men's,
uh,
tendencies towards aggression towards
kind of silly forms of competition towards
physical forms of violence.
Um,
you know,
that's what's been the
big problem all along.
Even though the world
has gotten a lot safer,
it's still may finish us off in the end.
Well,
that's the ultimate fear,
right?
The ultimate fear is that one dick waving
contest will lead to nuclear war and
then we'll all be fucking so plausible.
Knocking rocks together,
start fires.
So plausible,
especially look at some
parts of the world,
they were like fucking way closer
than we are to Russia to chill.
Like you look at like what North Korea
has threatened to do to South Korea,
what Pakistan and India,
when they look at each
other and you mother Fucker,
I got a missile at your name on it.
Easy.
All it takes is the wrong guy
with the right amount of power.
And that can happen and it's very likely
that we're saying guy for a reason.
It's not going to be the wrong woman.
Yes.
You know,
and yeah,
there is a certain,
there's certain reality that,
but there's also certain reality to the
fact that the reason why we have these
thoughts and ideas and the,
that we have this quote unquote toxic
masculinity in the first place is because
it served our genes well.
That's why we got to 2015 that's
why we fought off the competition.
And unfortunately,
I think there's a yin and a Yang to life.
There's a give and a take and there's an
action and a reaction when it comes to
aggression and when it comes
to fear and danger and that,
that reaction is innovation.
Um,
reinforcing the safer aspects of society,
law enforcement.
There's all these different reactions
to violence that lead to a better world.
Yeah.
And that's,
and that's really,
uh,
what the,
what the focus of my book is.
You know,
I,
again,
I expected to write a book with MMA
as a metaphor for this darkness is
blackness,
this danger,
this nastiness that the
core of human nature.
That's what I expected.
I wrote a very different book than that.
The book ended up being a book about
something that I call the monkey dance.
Um,
and,
uh,
if you've ever seen like a nature video
of two elephants seals clashing and the
server for two mountain
goats cracking skulls on a,
on a hillside,
biologists call those sorts of contests.
It call it ritual combat.
Um,
and ritual combat is a way that a
huge diversity of animal species have
developed to figure out who's bigger,
who's tougher,
who's stronger,
who's fitter without fighting
it out to the bitter bloody.
And like chimps grab sticks and
they pulled them out of the ground.
They beat the shit out of trees
with them more than people fight.
Exactly.
Yeah.
So Kim's have,
and that's the monkey dance.
Um,
and so in humans or animals too,
most people seem to like to forget this,
but what we're animals too,
we're complex animals
were cultured animals.
We're animals still.
And the monkey dance is my name
for human versions of ritual
combat.
Uh,
and it's a broad diversity of things.
Mainly men get up to things like
a deadly duals and verbal tools,
uh,
play fights among boys.
And,
and it's especially a sports.
And so a lot of these behaviors,
the key things that a lot of
these behaviors seem silly.
They seem stupid.
They seem pathetic there often volatile,
and they are in danger of escalating
to something truly dangerous.
But on the whole,
these monkey dances
are a good thing there.
A way that men can work
out their problems,
thrash out their status,
hierarchies in ways
that fall short of Apps,
you know,
all that allowed sorts of violence.
So the tips are a great example of this.
You know,
and humans do exactly the same thing.
If you're at a bar and you knock shoulders
with somebody and somebody spills
their beer,
um,
it's,
it's likely to go down like this.
There'll be some sort of insult us
with some sort of challenge them.
World Women feel disrespected,
dishonored,
uh,
they'll bluster back and forth.
Does that goes chimps in the jungle.
But at some 0.1 of the guys is like,
can I want to do this?
And you'll say,
sorry,
or you'll or you'll walk away.
Um,
and if you don't,
it continues to escalate.
The guys will close the distance.
So push the punch or tackle the cow.
We're talking about a totally
different sort of situation then.
Then competition when nowhere we're
talking about when you're talking about
bars,
you're talking about social things.
They talking about carve.
I mean,
honestly,
no one knows.
You know,
when you bumped into a guy in a bar,
you don't know who the
fuck you're dealing with.
You don't know anything about it.
You know,
you just,
it's a matter of a lot of chest puffing
and a lot of posturing and usually
enough sometimes.
But the,
what my take on it is,
is that there's a big,
there's a big difference between that
and what guys are doing to establish
greatness,
what they're doing too.
When you achieve
greatness in martial arts,
what you're essentially doing by becoming
a champion is you're showing a genetic
superiority.
You're sewing a mental superiority,
a character superiority that makes
you more preferred for breeding.
I mean,
that's just the reality situation.
Like I joke around about it,
but it's Kinda true.
The only reason why anybody gets laid his,
cause Luke Rockhold
didn't get there first.
So that was the greatest line.
And it's completely true.
It's so true.
My wife would have
little rock hold babies.
She could,
nobody wants to admit that,
you know,
because nobody wants to admit
that no man was not into that.
And it's not just the way he looks,
it's that he is that guy.
We are.
So we all,
we have an organic vegan
garden together and we,
you know,
we were amazingly connected.
Your wife wants to fuck Luke
Rockhold is deal with it.
No,
I think that's right.
I mean when it comes right down to it
and you walk around in the world and you
see these differences between men and
women and you see physical differences,
you see behavioral differences and you
naturally asking where does all this
stuff coming from?
And part of it comes from culture.
There's no doubt about it.
Uh,
but a lot of it is,
is biology.
It's total biology.
Women aren't showing up at
hospitals trying to fuck
dudes right before they die.
They're not trying to pull their
dicks out whether coffin blood,
he just something about
you're so vulnerable.
I need you inside me.
It's not,
this is not what they do.
They're,
they're attracted by power and strength
and character and not just strength as
far as like the ability
to oppress other people.
Like we traditionally
look at those things,
or it's in vogue to look at
those masculine characteristics
as being negative.
You know that Europe you're oppressing
others are the toxic masculinity handle,
but she's choosing a good
hunter and a good provider,
but also someone productive who
can deal when the shit goes down.
Some dudes,
they,
you know when they'll,
they'll chirp all around about toxic
masculinity or negative male behavior or,
but the reality is they don't
have any fucking character.
And if something happens
really bad in their life,
they start weeping and they fall apart.
And that's unattractive.
And the reason it's
unattractive to your friends,
if you have a friend and every time
something goes wrong in his life,
he starts crying and he wants a hug.
You like,
Jesus,
Bitch,
get your fucking shit together.
Come on dude.
And that's how,
that's how you're supposed to feel
because you know that that guy,
if anything goes wrong,
that guy's not going to be a good ally.
He's not a good ally.
He's not good to have in the tribe.
And these are unfortunate but realistic
aspects of being a human being.
In the 21st century.
It's still there.
I mean,
one day we might come to some point when
we have so much control over the world
that we live in,
that masculinity won't be unnecessary.
And that that's the case.
We'll probably evolve to the point
where we look like the aliens that are
depicted in every movie
with a giant hand muscles,
no muscles,
and the giant head that uses
telekinesis to move things.
I mean,
that's probably where we're headed.
yeah,
you're right.
I mean,
the world has gotten softer and softer
and safer and safer and we're still,
we're still,
uh,
carrying this baggage,
this evolutionary baggage of a,
of a sort of masculinity that's
best suited to a world where,
you know,
there's barbarians at the gates
and bears in the woods and uh,
all that,
all that stuff.
But in this same world,
there are avenues to express this
maximum masculinity where you can be
completely civil,
when you can be completely kind,
you can be a generous person,
but get over your own genetics in a way.
Give yourself difficult tasks to do.
And even what we were
talking about earlier,
fucking yoga can do that.
It doesn't have to be beating the shit
out of each other in a cave two and a
cage to achieve this,
but,
but the victory over your own self.
That's what it is.
Yeah.
That's what I,
that's why I didn't know going in.
That's why I didn't know going in.
I figured,
I figured those guys must
like beating people up.
It's muscle muscle.
I think some do take Abbott.
It comes to mind when I
think of the UFC level,
maybe there's more of those guys,
but you know I'm,
I'm,
I'm doing this very small time.
Amateur fighters and western
Pennsylvania and Ohio,
a 99% of them are amateurs.
99% of them have no hope of ever
winning any fame or fortune there.
There is no fame or fortune to be one.
So why are they doing it?
They're doing it because they
want a challenge in their,
they want a quest
in their life and they want to do battle
with their own weakness in their own
timidity and tried to defeat it.
Then you're not dreaming
about hurting people.
That's the way to express it.
Do battle with their own weakness.
That's why we,
everyone's like,
we have disdain for people that pick on
folks that they know that they can beat.
If you see a guy and he's a bully and
he's like a 250 pound guy and he wants to
fight a hundred pound guy,
why is you want to do that?
He wants to do that cause he's scared
of a challenge cause he's a coward.
Yeah.
I'll read a 250 pound
man would never want,
I mean the only time you would threaten
a hundred pound man is that a hundred
pound man was threatening a hundred
pound woman or something or the other
hundred pound man.
You're trying to step
in and keep the peace,
but when you see a bully look,
it's one of the most disgusting
characteristics because
we know ultimately it's
cowardice.
Cowardice.
It appears his strength because
they're flaunting their superiority,
but it's really cowardice.
Yeah,
and that's a thing that's going
to come somebody their own size.
Yeah.
I mean,
there was a,
here's a perfect example,
there was a fighter
that fell out of a card,
um,
cause he got injured and they offered
this other fighter replacement and he
said,
no,
I don't want to fight that guy.
But then he listed off a bunch of guys
that he would fight that we're like way
below him.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean,
and his,
his idea was like,
hey,
I have to change a
opponents and four weeks.
I don't want it to be difficult.
And everybody was like big,
like the mixed martial arts,
the underground forum.
It was fucking a wash with people angry.
And they're right.
They are right.
You know,
either you are willing to fight another
top contender who's just as capable of
beating you as you are of him.
Or we're wasting fucking time here,
you know?
And we don't want to watch that.
You've got to understand like
what did you sign up to do?
You signed up to be a fucking gladiator.
Okay.
You signed up to be the most noble of
all martial arts combatants of all time.
You're competing at the highest level
we've ever achieved in Marshall,
like today.
Make no mistake about it.
The fighters of today
are the highest skilled,
the most competent martial
artists that have ever existed.
There's some been some great
judo because of the past.
There's been some great
taekwondo competitors and
great Moitai fighters has been
great fun.
But as far as like the overall combination
in the form of a mixed martial artist
today,
they're the best that they've ever been.
No doubt about it.
I've by orders of magnitude.
Yeah.
I mean,
I'm a student of this.
I mean a long,
a lifelong student.
I've been deeply involved in
martial arts and I was 14 years old,
so I,
I'm,
I've seen all the levels.
I've seen the difference.
There's a difference between someone who
is doing it to achieve greatness and a
difference to someone who's like barely
getting by and they're really physically
talented and they train really hard,
but they're fucking terrified
of a real challenge.
And those guys exist and they exist even
at a very high level because they're
coming,
they come from really good camps,
they're really well trained.
And they have,
you know,
they have a bunch of
success under their belt,
but they're always terrified.
The one guy who is going to expose them.
It's
one of the most fascinating aspects.
It's also bad business to lose.
Yes.
You know,
it's,
those boxers you know,
are,
are notorious for padding their
records and fighting tomato cans.
And there's also,
there's some guys that
fold under pressure.
It's one of the most impressive
things about Jon Jones.
Um,
is it Jon Jones has overcome
adversity in his career in a,
in a very,
very obvious character defining way.
Like a good example is
the fight with Gustafson.
He talked to the people
that are in John's camp.
They'll tell you,
like,
he barely trained for that
fight to barely trained for him.
But God,
he did out in those last rounds and,
and saved his title.
The Vitor Belfort fight is
another perfect example.
Veto caught him and out
fucking deep armbar.
His arm was totally hyperextended.
99% of the population on
this planet plus who it tap.
I'm tapping to thinking about it.
I mean it was fucked up.
His,
his elbow was fucked up for
a long time after that too,
which is one of the reasons why he had
to coach the ultimate fighter and wound
up,
you know,
going through that because he really
couldn't compete is it was jacked.
His elbow was fucking jagged,
but he wouldn't have,
he wouldn't tap and he
went on to win that fight.
Anyone on the winded by submission,
he submitted a black belt in
Brazilian Jujitsu in Vito Belfort.
Yeah.
I just think that that
quality is something that is
almost impossible to teach.
Like you either have it or you don't,
or you maybe you can gain
it if you didn't have it.
Maybe you can put up these
boundaries in your mind where you,
you won't quit any more.
You won't allow you to some,
some,
uh,
native element to it.
You know,
some of it,
some people are born tough and born
with that kind of character horn.
I think it's developed over the course
of the adversity that you faced in your
life.
I think that's right.
But you know,
that was one of the big findings
for me at the gym is like,
you know,
you go into the gym and it's like,
ah,
what's a fighter and promote people.
I think most people
think a fighter is like,
I dunno person is strong and fit
and has developed this tool kit.
Uh,
you know,
all these sophisticated
techniques and all that stuff,
but should talk to fighters.
They don't define a fighter that way.
It just find it a fighter is,
you know,
a person who's really tough and who
will fight and whose game and a fight.
Um,
and that was one the thing that I found
sort of interesting going in because one
of my,
one of the things I wondered about
was whether I'd be able to do it,
just go in there and a
square off with people.
I didn't think I was ever
going to be good at it,
but could I just kind,
I compete bravely and I,
and I do think that you do build
your character by doing it.
You do get,
you do get stronger
and tougher and braver,
um,
through the process of,
you know,
of training?
No,
I think so.
Do I think there's no doubt about that.
I think there's also,
it's,
it's curious to me that there's a bunch
of people that are fight fans that are
they and even fighters that don't respect
people that don't put themselves at
risk
like a Floyd Mayweather
as a perfect example.
I don't get that at all.
I don't get it at all either.
I look at Floyd Mayweather
and I see a genius.
I see a guy who's obviously troubled in
his personal life and his treatment of
women is atrocious and all that,
all of the above.
I mean,
he's got all these arrests
for domestic violence.
I mean,
where there's smoke,
there's fire,
right?
Oh,
he spent time in jail for that gotta be,
or he's hanging out with chicks that
everyone and anyone would smack.
That's possibility too,
that nobody wants to
take into consideration.
I mean,
you're hanging around with that dude.
why are you hanging around with that dude?
I mean,
you know,
we,
you're attracted to him while he's rich.
Yeah.
Is that what it is?
Who knows?
Who knows what,
what the variables are?
But what's undeniable,
like,
I don't know him.
I don't want to judge his character.
What's undeniable about what
you can view is inside the ring.
He's a fucking genius.
He's brilliant.
The way he gets guys to dance,
to his tune,
he slows punchers down.
He slows volume punches down dramatically.
He,
he gets them to second.
Guess what they're doing.
He gets them off their game.
He lights them up,
he tags them,
he clinches them.
He just fights brilliantly.
He's,
the whole point of fighting is to
do damage without getting damaged.
But he doesn't do that much damage.
That's why people get crazy.
Yeah.
He does a little bit of damage,
but score than anybody else.
But in doing so,
he's beat the fucking game.
I mean,
he's 48 and oh yeah.
And he's never been knocked down.
He's never been stopped.
He's never been really hurt.
I said,
been knocked down.
Maybe he's been knocked down.
It might've been knocked down
like early in his career.
I think people were reacting.
They're not to the lack of,
you know,
carnage.
I think going back to the lack of drama,
you know,
people are,
people are attracted to fighting sports.
I think for a lot of reasons.
You know,
there's probably a creature in
us that kind of likes violence.
Um,
but there's also this sort of
a drama to a fight that's hard.
I mean with that fight
you have these two guys.
Do you have the,
you have the,
you have the good guy,
you have the face,
you have the heel squaring off in this
incredibly climactic showdown that's
going to define the story of their entire
careers and you're expecting some sort
of epic battle to go down that's
going to be incredibly gripping drama.
And then as a sort of dramatic spectacle,
I think it sort of fell flat because why?
That's my sort of theory for why the,
the,
the reaction to the fight was so negative.
Yeah.
I guess,
man,
I mean just when you're dealing with
two of the best boxers of any generation
who I think Manny Pacquiao,
I think it's safe to say that 95% of
them don't know anything about boxing.
That is a problem.
Boxing fans,
that's a Roger Mayweather.
He says famously it's a quote.
Most people don't know shit about
Bach ever seen they say that.
No,
but it's true.
It's a medium.
Anytime there's anything on the,
on the underground or time,
people talk about boxing,
but you're able to appreciate as a,
as an officiant auto.
Yeah.
And somebody is really sophisticated
and your knowledge of the sport,
whereas most people are just
wanting to see an intense drama.
Well,
I watched it with my wife
has never been in a fight in her life
and doesn't know Jack Shit about psychic.
It's kind of funny,
you know,
because you know,
if you look at our Dvr,
it's a,
it's like two competing philosophies,
reality shows versus she
doesn't watch reality shows,
but she's,
you know,
she's very much into different
shit that I'm into and I don't,
I don't mind that.
I don't and she doesn't mind,
but I,
but it's like when our path
or our interests cross and
she watches what I watch,
WWE becomes hilarious cause she
doesn't know anything about fighting.
Right.
She actually said this to me,
I've said this a bunch of times in the
podcast I promised the last time I say it
to anybody who's listening.
She actually says you should have
to get knocked down in order to win.
And I go,
what are you talking about?
She goes with Ellie will
make them fight more.
I'm like,
he's fighting.
Know God damn woman.
Like you don't understand
what's happening here.
This guy is,
he's doing what he wants to do.
He's if he stood in front
of Manny Pacquiao and they
just went rock 'em sock 'em
robots with fucking anything can happen.
But the way he's doing it,
he's controlling all the variables.
He's controlling it,
but he's controlling it with his skill
and his dedication and his practice and
his knowledge and he's,
he's information chunking.
That's,
that's something that I really truly
appreciate about high level Jujitsu
artists,
about high level martial
artists in any venue.
I love watching people
problem solve in real time,
much better than anybody else is doing.
And that's what he does.
Like he knows like he knows
how you're gonna react to it.
Thanks pop.
And it'll like poppy with that jab and
he knows that you're going to look to
step to your left and
he's already out of there.
He's already like when many pack yet would
step in and throw that right hook and
Floyd would dip to his left and
duck and slide right off the ropes.
It was genius,
the artistic,
you know,
he planned it perfectly.
He knew the pat cow is a certain type
of blitz style and Floyd just wasn't
there.
Still enjoy watching
boxing or do you find it,
uh,
kind of boring after watching MMA?
Um,
it's not as fun,
but I still love it like a,
I really love watching Canelo Alvarez
fight cause it's fights are fucking chaos.
Gennady Golovkin who funds this weekend,
he's the best.
Golovkin is the best to
watch because you know,
someone's getting knocked the fuck out.
Like that guy just is a destroyer.
He just seeks and destroys,
seeks and destroys.
And just slowly chips away at the best
of them to the point where they just
can't take it anymore and
their body starts giving out.
He's amazing.
You know,
he's had 300 and fucking 50 something
fights when you count his amateur career.
Wow.
He's amazing.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
Never been knocked down.
Never been dropped.
Never been hurt.
And he's knocked out every one.
I mean,
and you look at him,
he looks like he's in a boy band.
Little Sweetie.
Look at his face.
He's got a big smile and the way he talks,
I bring big drama fight.
It's amazing.
I said always amazing me.
Drama shows sport where one person
is so much better than everyone else.
It's not Roger Federer in tennis or
it's not necessarily that he is so much
better than everyone else.
He's so much better than
everyone he's fought.
He has to fight a Mayweather or maybe
there's a little smaller than him.
His father,
the ways Floyd senior said that.
Yeah,
he ain't find no damn giant.
A giant.
He's fucking my size.
It's fun.
Eight or something,
or five nine who's not a big guy,
you know,
he's just amazing.
But he's won 60 fights at one 60.
And me,
whether it's a one 47.
Yeah.
So I kind of get it.
But,
uh,
if Canelo Alvarez,
I think he's big enough to fight them.
I think that would be a
fucking fantastic fight.
God Alvarez and Gennady Golovkin would
be fucking amazing because Alvarez,
I mean,
he could knock out anybody.
Yeah.
Anybody.
And so can glove gun.
I think Golovkin is a bit
more skilled than him.
A bit more,
more refined and more technical.
But Khan Damn Alvarez
is a fucking monster.
He's a monster.
That would be exciting.
You know,
a survey called Kovalev is another really
exciting guy and he's Russian dudes
are not regular white people.
They just are not so true.
We need to get that in our head folks.
He let these guys turn Europeans.
Uh,
you know,
it was coming from hardscrabble
backgrounds and how about
fucking thousand years
of hard scrabble genetics.
That's right.
Yeah.
And not these pussy Americans.
We're dealing with Bella tour.
A bunch of tough Russians.
Fuck.
Yeah,
they do.
Sure.
Manco who's that Little Chi?
Uh,
the fade or not fade or
what do they call him?
The Lord of Frodo.
You ever seen him fight?
Oh yeah.
What the fuck is his knees?
A little,
well,
there's a bunch of really high level
Russian guys that are in the UFC now too.
Like a hubby even number got met off.
Yeah,
it was another Aka guy.
But you know,
I watched a video of him wrestling
Luke Rockhold and I'm like,
how come a fucking guy who fights at
one 55 is fighting the biggest one?
Eight F is wrestling the biggest 185
pounds of the world's ever known.
What is going on in there?
Does he wrestle cane too?
I mean what,
when,
how?
Cause I know that Rockhold wrestles came.
Yeah.
Where do you guys end us?
Cause he spar with DC.
I mean he's won 55.
What the fuck is going on?
So he blew out his knee
again and you know,
he's supposed to be fighting
cowboy in my fight of the year.
I fucking love that fight.
Yeah.
Ooh,
that's a stylistic fight.
I mean [inaudible] you got the best
grappler I think in the division in Habib
versus one of the very best
strikers and all of the UFC.
I mean,
Donald is such a good morning tie striker.
He's so good.
He's so good at,
I mean you,
when you see him fight a guy
that is not at his level,
that's when you really understand how
good he is and you see him fight like a
Jim Miller and see what
he could do to those guys.
That's where you kind of get in your head.
You're like,
wow,
this guy's on.
He's on a very high level right now.
Something.
Yeah,
it's also super confident.
Super prepared.
He's been fighting so often and he's
like just in the groove right now.
This is his time trying to bulletproof.
I mean,
he fights so much and you fight
so hard and it's tough as shit,
man.
He just holds up.
He,
you know,
he's just tough as shit.
That's just like who he is.
He's the real deal.
I mean,
that guy in his spare time,
he rides bulls,
gets on fucking bowls and rides him.
He just,
he jumps,
he keeps the most dangerous
sport in the world by the way.
But it's not as bold.
That's just people being assholes.
You get call it a support.
This is ridiculous.
It was a great article in the New Yorker
about bull riding and it's amazing.
It's,
it'd be a sport of the
bull signed up for it.
If the bowls,
what?
Yeah.
Man.
I want to see if I can
fucking shake a dude.
They breed these bolts out.
They breed them to shake.
They breed would be violent.
They breed be dangerous.
Of course they do.
And they,
uh,
and the,
the highest rate of head injuries,
neck injuries.
We had a guy on fire for
injuries that had his,
his elbow or shoulder
rather just destroyed.
He was a professional bull rider and he
showed me a scar is I get took off his
shirt and his whole like is,
is he had like lines everywhere
connecting his shoulder to his,
his jigsaw puzzle.
How many times he had surgery and he had
some fucking ungodly number of shoulder
soldier.
I don't even remember,
like nine or 10 and he goes,
anything goes wrong.
It just pops out.
Like if he falls wrong,
which is pops out and then I
need someone to like Yank on it.
Yeah,
I guess you got to extend
it in a pop back in place
and all for what to so he can get that
eight seconds on a monster and hot.
The same thing.
I tell him,
man,
you know,
it seems crazy to people from the outside,
but there's a certain challenge to it.
There's a quest to it.
I would hop in array.
I would agree to three
fights in the night before.
I would agree to ride a bull.
No doubt about it.
When you're fucking doubt about it,
you're not very good
at writing good at it.
The best,
the best guy could do eight seconds.
Did you fucking do?
Everybody sucks it riding bulls.
If there was a dude out there that was
like the Michael Jordan of bull riding,
they could just ride bulls
for like a half an hour.
They're just kicking him
and shit and he's like,
what?
You know,
he's like blowing kisses
to his mom in the crowd.
Then I would say there's a guy that's
good at bull riding but everybody sucks.
It's just some guy saw that less.
I'm pretty good at regular blue line.
I was at this fair one time and uh,
they had one was mechanical
bowls and everybody's riding,
you know,
doing it right the one hand away.
I'm like fuck it,
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna beat this thing and I just,
I just clench.
I could on two hands,
hold onto it,
bury my face into it and its,
hold on,
you know,
how was that?
Hold on.
I wrote for like two minutes.
How wild have people booed me,
you know,
for cheating.
And the other half were like,
I never thought I got that.
Got the genius.
So you grab it like a rear naked choke.
You grab it.
Yeah.
Like you're like you're pulling
guard as hard as you possibly can.
But wait a minute.
Okay,
let me think.
You seen him mechanical ball,
but where are you grabbing it?
You can just kind of grab around.
It's like you pull a picture
of a mechanical bullet please.
A pommel horse in gymnastics.
You're the pommel horse in gymnastics.
Trying to like that.
You can just kind of get under
it with both of your hands.
You put your face into it.
I'm a very curious now because I rode
one of those things for some stupid MTV
thing and I was shocked at how
easy it was to them to fly me off.
That fucker.
I hadn't any last five seconds.
I wrote for like two minutes.
That's insane.
Oh there's a bunch of different kinds.
Huh?
Some of them actually
looked like a real cow.
I wrote the cow kind.
The one that looks like a cow.
Did it have horns or no,
I don't think he had horns.
We had rubber horns,
but I could,
I could get right around
his head cause a real horns.
That was,
um,
okay,
so you can get you out one.
That one right there.
I see that one with,
with the fair where they
have the bubble around it.
You know the,
that right there.
Yeah,
that one.
Then I could click on that.
That's when I wrote,
you can just get him around the neck.
You kind of choke them out.
Huh?
You clinch real hard.
Like he's,
his head was bigger so you don't know
if you could get around his head.
Yeah.
That guy's riding it like a moron.
Well that's why they called
the rear naked choke.
The lion killer.
They say there's only
one way to kill a lion.
He got a choke.
It kind of choke it out.
Get it back to get it back.
I think.
Good luck getting your fucking
arms around the lines neck.
It's hard to get.
Your alarms are how big guys?
No,
I know.
Yeah.
Get your arms here.
Those guys that I could,
I can't choke.
Yeah,
I mean you could,
but it's not easy.
But a lion is strong as fuck.
They weigh 500 pounds in a bowl,
so,
okay,
so you reach under and what are
you grabbing with your arms?
Well,
again,
his neck is too big,
but it's an action in his
neck was a little smaller.
And just get your arms around his neck.
Do you ask grip it?
I think I did.
I did something like that probably
so it was a small mechanical bull.
He might his bitch ass.
He was killing her fluff.
You were riding a mechanical cow.
So I'm like a calf maybe they feel
this is one of my best moments.
I don't have any moments of Vixxo.
People booed you.
Half of them booed me for cheating,
you know,
because it was obviously like counter
to the spirit of it broke the code.
He figured it out.
But it was tough though.
I mean my face was all like a cut out.
Yeah.
You get anything out of it or just pride?
I got probably got a lot of pride out.
I'm telling you about it on the air.
This was my big moment.
Yeah.
The idea of riding a giant animal.
First of all,
I don't like the idea of
raising those things to do that.
I don't like,
I don't even like zoos,
man.
I go to zoos and it drives me nuts.
Bull fighting.
I don't know if it's,
I don't know if it's bad.
More fucked up.
Both hands.
Way More fucked up cause I don't think
there's anything bad that really happens
to the boy.
He didn't like cause people on his back
and he bucks him off ferociously and
they're only on there for eight seconds
and some of these bowls are smart and
they figured out how to hurt people.
Like they know if they,
if they buck and just a certain way while
throwing their head back at the same
time,
you know they can really do damage to
people and get these people off their
back.
Jesus Christ.
Some of them are basically killers and
they have to be retired because they get
too good at it.
It's article in the New Yorker,
man.
I'm not telling you Google
New Yorker in both fighting.
It's amazing article.
Both fighting boom.
Right?
Yeah,
both fighting.
I'm hugely opposed to,
yeah,
that drives me crazy.
I just,
first of all,
there's a bunch of people sticking that
thing with poisoned arrows are poison
darts poisoned,
poisoned.
I mean it's barbaric but there's one of
the great books about combat sport is
Hemingway's death in the afternoon.
If you haven't read that,
I'd really recommend it because almost
everything he says about bull fighting,
uh,
is re relevant,
you know,
to other forms of combat sport.
You know,
it's really,
really a great book.
They had some sort of poison,
they using those spears and the Jab.
I don't believe so.
The,
the,
the spears are basically what they do.
They,
they drain energy from
the animal and they also,
and they also force it
to put his head down.
Um,
and that's important because the killing
stroke needs to be delivered over the
horns.
And so until the,
what we wanted to have a very
clean balletic a type of kill,
um,
which,
which means that they have to have
to get the animal's head arrange in a
downward position so they
can get the sword to go home.
So where are they trying to drive it into?
It's like a spinal call.
Like I've seen him do it,
but no,
I think to go for the heart.
But they go in and we'll then go back.
They go in with a,
you know,
a two foot,
three foot sore all the way to the hill.
Well yeah,
they're going to go and right to the hill.
It goes in like butter.
Jesus Christ.
Did they eat the bull after they do that?
Cause bowls are not that delicious.
Right.
I have no idea.
I imagine they do it and these are
peasants societies that you know,
uh,
develop this custom and I'm sure they,
they ate the ball.
Well,
most people aren't aware that
if you buy steak in a market,
you're getting an animal
that's been neutered.
Yeah.
You get what's called a steer and they
take a bowl and they cut his balls off
and he's young and they let them
grow to size and then they kill him.
So he has a more tender meat.
If you eat,
like I shot a moose in,
um,
this guy right here in British Columbia.
That's him.
Yeah.
This monkey boil his face.
Well I had a guy do it.
I didn't do it myself.
I'm busy,
dude.
I got shit to do.
But yeah,
it's called a European mounts,
like easing the structure
of the inside of his,
his nose.
Oh yeah.
They're,
no,
they're not there.
Their nostrils are incredible.
It's amazing.
That's a deer is a little different.
They're both dear.
That's the largest deer in North America.
So how much your speeches,
your moose,
that's a moose cause it
doesn't look like a Mousse.
It's a small moves.
That's why he was only
a couple of years old.
So he was only 900 pounds.
Wow.
But I'm a big moose.
Pounds is huge.
It is.
But not for a moose to get my friend
shot one that was 1400 pounds.
Wow.
But my point being that the muscle,
like the tissue is really dense.
Like there's some areas like the back,
like the tenderloins and the
backstraps that are more,
more of a tender meat.
Right.
But the,
uh,
the tissue of a Moose is so right.
It's a fucking unbelievably
powerful animal that,
I mean they,
when that his,
if he got older he would have these huge
fucking saloon doors grown out of his
head and then he would use
those to slamming the other
dudes who also have those
things and they're just so strong.
So the meat is like really tough.
Yeah.
They haven't been bred for
eons to be a hamburger.
Exactly.
And my friend shot a water buffalo in
Australia and he said they cooked the back
strap,
which is like the most tender part.
And he said he had a piece of meat in his
mouth that he chewed for half an hour.
He's not joking,
said he's practicing his bone out and he
was practicing for a half an hour with
one piece of meat in his mouth
and he was trying to break down.
I mean,
we're so,
we're such pussies were so soft and mushy.
Like we're,
you know,
we're talking about like cage fighting
and like amazing and get in there and you
fighting against a person.
Oh,
I know.
I felt about it a lot of times
about how scared I was when I would
think about like how much harder,
you know other people have it.
You know,
I was reading other,
other memoirs of people like
who did dangerous things,
especially like war reporters
like Sebastian younger
went over and wrote books
about the Afghanistan war.
We went into this little platoon
way off in the middle of nowhere.
I mean they're really in the,
in the shit.
He got blown up in a home
v you know all kinds of,
you know,
bad ass stuff and he didn't complain
and bitch and Moan about it.
You went back.
I know that guy is nuts.
The bravery or those guys,
this is astonishing.
And so you compare to the cage has these
guys seem really brave and they are but
that's,
that's a whole nother level.
Well and Sebastian younger is
not even shooting back now.
He's writing.
Yeah and he's got his head up cause
he's got his camera cause he's,
he's videotaping all of this stuff.
You did two documentaries and you know,
bullets are flying and he's got his,
he's got his head up.
What kind of fucking
Ptsd does that guy have?
His friend,
his friend died,
you know,
like a week after,
or not recapture,
but as soon afterwards,
his,
his friend and the other camera man
got on Tim Hetherington was killed,
I believe in Libya.
Um,
and so yeah,
I think he's got some pretty
severe emotional insight,
psychological damage from it.
He,
he said he was not going back.
He said he's not going
back to war zones anymore.
Yeah.
I would say that's a good decision.
He knows when to quit.
Yeah.
But if it wasn't for guys like that,
are the people that film like Restrepo or,
Yeah.
That's who it is.
That was Hetherington and special,
younger.
And um,
there's a new documentary
that a younger as a fighter,
you know,
by the way,
was he?
Yeah.
Sebastian younger.
Read my book please.
Oh,
it looks like it is Moses kind of,
yeah,
he's a he he boxes,
uh,
still I believe so.
Yeah,
I do.
So he's a tough guy.
That's one of the things that I
really wanted to talk to you about.
Um,
when,
uh,
I had heard this concept
of professor in the cage,
the protecting of essential
cognitive function,
which is necessary to pursue your career.
Yeah.
I mean,
did you find there was any
negative repercussions physically?
Did you feel anything time?
Uh,
the first time I got punched
really hard in the face,
um,
was really educate.
It's really educational,
you know,
because watching from outside the cage,
you kinda know like,
you know,
this isn't good for these people.
You kind of know what
to brain damage contest,
but it's different actually feel it.
And,
uh,
the first time I got
knocked around pretty good,
um,
and,
and afterwards kind of felt
concussed even during the,
the attack,
even when I was getting,
taking these shots,
um,
I was able to think to myself,
you know,
uh,
I try,
I make my living trying to think smart
thoughts and I better quit while I still
know my alphabet.
Um,
but I didn't.
but what was the,
was the negative aspects of it?
I don't know.
I mean,
I don't think I had a
lot of headaches and,
uh,
occasionally I would,
I would be,
I'd be cloudy,
you know,
for a day or two afterwards,
there's this sort of just barn.
Yeah,
I'd be like a little,
I felt like it was like,
you know,
describe it.
It's sort of like a translucent blanket
thrown over my head and slowed my
thinking and clouded my perception.
Did you ever get that same sort of feeling
just from hard training where you're
exhausted and all this is
definitely a time where,
uh,
a couple of times I got,
you know,
again,
one of the situations you're
inspiring and guys hit you too hard.
And there was a couple of guys who are
notorious for it and I got really jacked
up.
I buy it by a few guys,
um,
one time where,
you know,
it's kind of just landed this
brutal left hook against me.
Um,
and he didn't really mean to like,
he apologized afterwards.
I was moving in,
you know,
he tagged me hard.
Um,
and,
you know,
I was almost knocked out,
uh,
you know,
saw stars,
uh,
the whole world,
my perception of the world
for artist torques flipping,
flipping over,
the lights are kind of
going on and off and,
um,
but I didn't,
I,
you know,
with brain damage,
it's usually a time bomb that
goes off sometime in the future.
So you don't,
you know,
is there isn't,
there isn't.
There's also,
um,
there's an accumulative damage issue,
but there's also a,
I've met guys where I knew them and then
they had one really hard fight and then
they were different.
Yeah.
So I didn't,
I didn't have anything like that,
at least not to my knowledge.
I mean,
I'd have,
I'd have short term repercussions of it,
but how often will you sparring are,
Kim was not all that
enlightened of a place,
you know,
and the culture of it was pretty intense.
So I dunno,
probably probably twice a week.
Pretty hard sparring,
you know.
Um,
I'm always fascinated by people who know
the repercussions and still dive into
it and still just say,
you know what,
it's a,
it's worth the risk to what
everybody is doing nowadays.
Everybody knows the risks.
I don't,
I mean,
and then may fighters,
you know,
he's kind of either smart guys,
these are middleclass guys,
most of them college educated,
but a guy like you is different
because you're not really,
I mean you are an MMA fighter
and that you did fight,
but that's not like what you're pursuing.
It is my pursuit though.
My procedures,
writing books and I saw a good book in it,
so I did it for professional reasons too.
I mean there was,
there was a personal reason I'd
never been in a fight before.
I was kind of curious about
whether I was a coward or not.
Um,
and I wanted to do this brave
thing for me was a very,
it was a brave thing.
Um,
but there was also a professional thing
just like the fighters have and the
fighters are doing it because
they need to make a living.
Um,
I was doing it because I
wasn't making much of a living.
Um,
and I needed to try to do
something something up that would,
yeah,
that would shock shock a little bit,
shocked me out of my old ruts.
Um,
and write a book that had larger audience
than the books I'd written before,
which was sort of books
for English lit nerds.
Now what was the actual
experience of the fight?
Like talk us through the day of it.
What did you feel like when
you woke up in the morning?
You knew,
Holy Shit,
today's the day.
Uh,
I was,
you know,
there was a level of anxiety,
uh,
that was always there.
Um,
I was glad,
however,
but I didn't feel the terror
that I felt that I might fear.
I was afraid that I'd be so scared that
I'd like kicking out or just or just
behave in a,
in a coward,
the fashion.
Um,
and there was a lot of anxiety but
it wasn't as bad as I expected.
And when I got in the cage,
one thing that was
really interesting to me,
cause I didn't know this would happen,
is all of the feared
pretty much evaporated.
A fear is really,
really useful.
You know,
it's your body's way of saying to you,
dude,
this is really dumb,
really dumb.
Let's reconsider,
right?
See if there's a different
way to do this thing.
So it's useful going in.
But once you're in the cage
and you've been locked inside,
fear is no longer very useful.
Um,
cowering is not going to save you.
You know,
you're locked in.
There's no getting out of this thing.
And my fear just kind of went away and
it was replaced by something that was
really cool.
In retrospect,
it was this a sense of focus
that I'd never felt before.
Never felt before,
nothing close to it.
Like I was in this arena and
minor league hockey and Rena,
there's people there hooting and howling.
Um,
I saw nothing.
I heard nothing.
All I could see was
the guy in front of me.
All I could hear was him.
You know,
I've had this incredible tunnel vision.
So at some point my coach
was screaming at me,
you know,
uh,
screaming out instructions,
screaming out warnings,
and he's a loud guy and he's one of
these classic corner men whose voice just
fills the whole,
uh,
arena.
I had never heard it.
I never heard as there was
nothing in the world except for,
except for that guy.
Um,
so yeah,
that was,
how did the fight go?
Um,
you know,
I don't want to get
too much away about it,
but why is it in the book?
It's in the book and I sort
of build some suspense to it,
but you know,
you don't want to tell us what happened.
I'll tell you a little
bit about what happened.
Uh,
the fight was 47 seconds long.
Did you win?
I won the first 46 seconds and
in the fight took a nasty turn,
uh,
in the last second one second.
Pretty much.
Yeah.
It was pretty abrupt.
Uh,
I,
yeah,
for 46 seconds I was,
I was sort of imposing my will and things
were going my way and I was starting
to feel good.
Uh,
and then,
uh,
you know,
things went bad.
Yeah,
things went really bad and it was over.
It was that fast.
It was amazing.
Did you want to do it
again after it was over?
Desperately.
Really desperately and it
will seem to sweaty yet.
I wasn't even sweaty yet.
And I was like,
okay,
now I know how to do this.
Did you get hit or did you get choked?
I got her on bird.
That's not a bad way to lose.
No,
it wasn't,
but it wasn't part of it.
You know,
I'm approaching it as a writer and I
wanted to like a story that was more epic,
you know,
a more of a,
I don't know what,
it's more of a heroic struggle.
Something make a better story.
Um,
and part of it was,
you know,
I really screwed up.
I really screwed up in the
fight and afterwards I was like,
okay,
now I have this under my belt.
And I was almost positive that I
wouldn't have made that mistake again.
I would know how to do it.
I would,
I kinda need it really bad rookie mistake.
What was the mistake?
Well,
basically my strategy going in was I,
I was not,
I was always a better grappler
than I was to striker.
It wasn't that I was a great grappler,
but I was better at it than striking.
And so we didn't know
anything about the guy.
Other guy.
We knew nothing.
He had no Google.
Um,
we didn't know if he was a striker,
a grappler.
We didn't know if he's left
handed or right handed.
These are all really
bad things not to know.
And so the game plan was us,
we take them down and try to
make them fight me off his back.
Cause that's what I did best.
Um,
so you know,
right off,
right off the bat,
you know,
within,
a few seconds I shot,
got a takedown.
Um,
God,
I'm down against the fence was about
this close to securing the mount.
You know,
I,
he kind of had me in a headlock.
I got out of it,
so my foot up and it was
almost in the mountain then,
you know,
that then was the first clue
that I was out of my league.
You know,
right away he just did
this really kind of fancy,
sophisticated thing,
redrew me effortlessly into the garden
and started working on that arm bar.
And uh,
I didn't,
and I knew something was bad,
something bad was happening.
And so I guess,
so I got up and I can't,
in Yankton,
Yankton,
Yankton got out and ran for it.
Okay.
He rose to his feet and chases me.
And at that point,
that was when,
uh,
unexperienced fighter would have said,
okay,
it's not a good idea to roll around
on it with this guy on the ground.
We need to change the plan.
And that's what my coach
is screaming at me.
You know,
he's,
he was screaming at me,
you know,
you don't want to go to
the ground with this guy.
Um,
and immediately,
you know,
I was,
I couldn't,
I couldn't break out of the game plan.
It never even occurred to me.
So I waited.
I sorta set that ambush.
We were waiting for the
guy to throw a punch,
throw kick and you shoe.
And,
uh,
that happened,
you know,
he kicked me in the,
in the ribs and a at the same,
same second I shot.
And it was this great moment in my life.
It was almost better than
the bull riding moment.
Um,
there's this great picture.
I got 'em,
you know,
perfect double leg,
take down,
you know,
he's airborne and we come down hard smack.
Um,
and,
and at this point I feel
like I'm in control.
This fight,
I'm winning,
everything is going great.
Uh,
and the next thing I know,
I mean,
one second,
two seconds later,
uh,
he'd somehow swept me.
It was like,
it wasn't,
it was a fancy arm bar.
You know,
I'm,
I was a white belt at best,
um,
and it's a fancy arm bar where he
managed to sort of flipped me over like a
pancake and,
you know,
next thing I know I'm looking up at the
ceiling instead of looking down and it
was tight and it was just watch it.
I watched it.
Yeah.
But it took me a while to even
figure out what he had done.
Is it available online?
Uh,
no,
I don't think so.
I have the video.
I could show you what I'd
like to see a transition.
Yeah.
What he did.
I,
I could,
I could show you like we could get on
the ground here and I can show you.
Okay.
You,
you see,
you,
I'm sure we really,
really basic,
super basic.
But you know,
for me,
my,
you know,
I'm only a year into this at this
point in my Jujitsu was pretty,
uh,
it was pretty rudimentary.
One of the things,
and this is going to seem weird that I've
been noticing about a yoga is getting
into yoga again recently is the
various complexities of each position.
It's not,
it's not as simple as like,
put your leg here,
stand up,
there's like back has to be straight
and you expand your chest back,
push down with your heels,
you know,
push your hips forward.
There's all these different
variables that you have to take.
Any consideration and
every single posture will,
the same
exists in Jujitsu just on
a much more complex level.
There's so much because you're attacking
someone and then they're defending and
then you're anticipating the defense and
setting up a second attack off of that
defense.
Oftentimes the first attack is just
to gauge how they will respond.
And then,
you know,
and there's the chaining,
all the like Helson Gracie of Steve
Maxwell's famous of strength and
conditioning coach,
Jujitsu black belt,
um,
been on this podcast a few times,
described how Helson Gracie
describes Jujitsu and he goes,
uh,
cause he's got,
you know,
kind of a pre deep accent and he goes,
you do this,
then I do that,
then I do this.
Then you do that forever.
Yeah,
that's good.
It's a great way to describe it.
And the more you understand
about each position,
the more you understand about where,
where could things go wrong,
where can things go,
right?
What,
what,
what are you trying to achieve?
And when you don't know that,
like you,
the way you're describing it,
you're like,
what's happening?
I had no idea how am I this or that.
He did this and it was over.
And so my husband was like,
why?
I wanted to fight again,
like right then afterwards
was because I knew that,
you know,
I had chosen exactly the wrong game
plan to fight this guy and afterwards we
became Facebook friends and I see all
of his pictures on his Facebook page,
Him with gold medals on his chest from
winning Jujitsu competition tournament.
Yeah.
So he's [inaudible] out of my league.
Is he a black belt?
I don't believe so.
Uh,
but yeah,
he was up there.
Have you considered just really training
hard as you did to try to look through?
I'd like to do,
yeah,
I can get help if I can get
healthy and 42 it's tough.
I know.
Well the problem with me is know this
is why I think I had so many physical
problems.
It's like there is a nature
and nurture to flexibility.
You know,
some people have,
you know,
some people have really high
vertical leap by just by nature.
You know,
some people were really flexible.
It just,
by nature I appear to be the Chi who's
not very flexible by nature when I work
on it really hard.
But boy,
I just don't seem to get
much more flexibility oppose
that because no one in my
family is flexible by button.
Me.
And the reason why I'm flexible is
because my body developed by stretching.
I mean I was stretching from
the time I was really young.
That could be a starting when
you're young and supple him.
But when I was in my
early twenties you know,
if you're doing karate,
there's a lot of stuff
you just can't do if you,
if you're not very flexible.
And so I worked on really hard.
Well there was a guy that used
to come to our Jujitsu gym.
This is one of the reasons why I pose it.
And he was just big fucking football
player and he was like 250 pounds.
And whenever I used to roll with them,
I used to literally say I'm going to
go ride the bull because that was,
that was what was,
it was like rolling with him.
Like he wasn't good.
I think I was a brown belt and I
think he was a white belt at the time.
And so I would always get them.
But it would be a while.
I mean it would be like,
ah fuck you,
like hanging onto this guy for
a long time and riding the bull.
But this guy was a dedicated athlete
and one of the things that he did was he
radically improved his while he was there
when he first started out.
You know how you sit there like with
your legs in a butterfly position and you
try to push your,
your,
your knees down to the ground.
He couldn't even come close.
His knees are like stock up like this.
He couldn't push them down and all,
but that fucking guy would be there
after class for 40 minutes longer than
anybody else.
Just stretching,
stretching,
just pushing his soft tissue
to the limit every day.
And it's that kind of dedication
that led to a year plus later.
Like my friend Eddie Bravo,
my Jujitsu instructor as well,
he always talks about that guy.
This one guy he fucking put in the time,
put in the numbers and
he got really flexible.
I mean,
he was almost had a full split
after like a year and a half,
but it was the kind of dedication
that led him to be a football player.
I mean he was a professional
athlete and he just,
this guy just fucking put on the
blinders and went for flexibility.
He knew he was ridiculously strong.
He knew he was ridiculously powerful.
So he had to learn the technique and
you had to get flexible and so he,
he,
I saw him do it,
man.
I saw it take place.
So whenever,
when someone says they said,
Oh,
you'll have certain
restrictions in this certain,
it was only Sophie.
That's all the time.
You say that not everyone's
given the same genetic gifts.
Yes,
no doubt about that.
When it comes to Fast Eddie Bravo,
you know,
like he's just a freak.
He has some freakish flexibility
in some areas he does,
but it's also,
he's stretched those areas ad nauseum.
I mean that guy,
you'd be watching TV with him and
he's pulling his foot to his chest.
Like seriously everywhere too though.
I watched,
I watched TV.
I'm going to instruct the whole time.
I don't,
you know,
I don't know how much you're stretched.
I don't know how much you stretch,
but I do know that I watched this guy do
it and I watched this guy get way more
flexible and it was amazing.
But this is what my point is,
is like there are unquestionably
physical gifts that you can't,
you can't achieve like fast twitch,
muscle fibers,
speed and power cardio to cardio.
Cain Velasquez is the one
that they always bring up,
size of bones,
size of the hands,
the width of the shoulders,
all those things contribute to power.
And also like the explosion,
like the fast guys,
like a guy like Uriah hall,
like Uriah Hall without a doubt is
trained very hard and well prepared and he
has excellent technique.
But you watch your Riaa hall shoot a
straight right hand and you're like,
okay,
like I don't know how many
guys can do at that fast.
He'll,
he'll be like moving around and
all of a sudden you're like,
lean in with this right hand that cut
and you see the look on the guy's face
after he got hit where he
realizes like what just happened?
Whoa.
Like this guy's got some next level speed.
Like I was talking to your rise
coaches after one of his fights.
He's like,
he's the fastest fucking
guy I've ever seen.
Like the fastest guy.
Like you see him in the gym.
I mean he is so fucking
fast and some of that is,
I mean some,
some portion of that is
unattainable for the average person.
Yeah.
That's just the reality.
But it does.
Where do you think be
different for flexibility?
I think flexibility is something
that you can push because
it's just a matter of how
far your soft cardio toes.
No,
not really.
Can't push like crazy.
There's a linen.
Cassidy though is different.
The size of the heart
is different like this.
One of the things that we
said about Lance Armstrong,
he has an enormous heart
and that's part of,
that's part of it.
The training too though,
could be when you grow
the harder to muscle,
it atrophies.
It hypertrophies plus all
the shit that he took.
Crimes injecting steroids and one of
those ones from pulp fiction when they
revived.
Who knows?
Man,
who knows.
I just think that flexibility
is a little bit more simple.
I don't think you could
achieve the flexibility of
say like you have an anecdote
or you have your big friend.
I'm saying that I think I'm,
the other anecdote might be,
I've never seen you stretch though.
We'll do it after.
Okay,
let's see.
See how hard you push it.
Cause some people get to
a certain point like Ah,
okay,
but you got to get to that super,
I can't breathe point and
you gotta push that bitch.
It's just,
it's also like how do you do it?
Do you do it correctly?
Do you have someone who's
pushing you correctly in what,
where are you starting out from?
You starting out from 39 40 years of doing
Jack Shit to stretch out and then all
of a sudden you're trying to take
these mature older muscles and,
and pull them up on a big part.
That's a big part of that.
That's right.
If I've been sitting on a
desk for years and years,
I mean if somebody got ahold
of you when you were 16,
that's very possible.
And when you were doing Kyokushin did,
did,
did your school really
emphasize stretching?
I did.
You know,
cause I knew,
well I knew I couldn't kick guys in the
head and I knew I wanted to be able to,
you know,
cause that's a big part of
it is all kinds of kicks.
I get all kinds of cool
stuff I couldn't do.
So I got stretching machine,
you know,
I,
well it was chuck Norris jammies.
I know chuck north of knockoff
version cause it was cheaper.
Uh,
no crank.
No,
you'd have a crank.
mine was different was it was like,
what's some kind of like PVC.
Okay,
I know that time.
Yeah.
It was like a pilot picture par,
you pull it and stretch
exactly those do a little bit,
but realistically you don't need that
which you really need is just someone who
can help you and push you back down.
And then also the ability
to withstand pain.
That's it.
The uncomfortable feeling of
pushing your muscles to limit.
Yeah.
I don't mind that it's hard to,
uh,
it's hard to change
your body in many ways.
It's hard to develop more muscle
because your body doesn't want to,
your body doesn't want to change.
You know,
your body just wants to get really sore
and then discourage you from continuing
to lift right now in order to
force your body to gain weight.
Like if someone say to me,
hey man,
I want to put on about five pounds of
muscle while you're going to have to work
out three days a week,
like a madman for a year,
good luck.
You know,
there's one thing if you're a
dedicated professional athlete,
you've been doing it a long time and
your body knows how to grow and there's a
certain amount of also muscle memory
that comes into play when you see someone
who is a really big,
but then they lose the,
the muscle mass.
Like maybe they'll get into something
else and we'll stop lifting.
They can get really big way
quicker than the average person.
It's no,
it's a fact.
Like say if you,
if you used to weigh 230 pounds,
you big fucking giant dude and
then you dropped down to one 70,
you could gain,
like if you took two dudes that
weighed one 70 and they're both,
you know,
reasonably fit and one of
them used to be enormous,
he will get bigger quicker.
It's just muscle memory.
Yeah.
There's no,
there's no getting around that,
but your body doesn't want to do it.
It's,
you,
you have to really push that bitch.
And I think the same takes place
with flexibility and the same.
Um,
the same holds true with,
uh,
with gains,
with size gains.
It's very difficult to do.
Yeah,
you have to be willing to push your body
to this really uncomfortable position
and then you have to fuel
it with all sorts of food.
It's like,
hey,
didn't kick out of
whenever people compare,
like it's,
it's a funny thing like it happens on
my message board on my forum sometimes,
like people start talking about diets
and caloric requirements and then they'll
bring up like Michael Phelps.
Well,
Michael Phelps ate 15 fucking
pizzas a day and he did like,
do you have any idea how hard
Michael Phelps works out?
Yeah.
Don't ever fucking compare
yourself to Michael to stop.
He's in the greatest Olympic swimmer
the world has ever known and whatever
genetic gifts he has,
they were unquestionably accentuated
by a barbaric worth ethic.
And we,
those things helped.
I think that we'd help
them recover and he's six,
seven or eight big,
giant fucking long dude.
But also the amount of calories
that guy was burning every day.
The average person really can't relate.
You just,
you can't relate.
No.
Like the amount of effort that
it takes to be a Chris Weidman,
the kind of training camps at
Vitor Belfort goes through what,
you know,
what Jon Jones went through when
you train for Daniel Columbian.
It'd be interesting when,
when the,
with the stronger drug testing,
see if these guys can go
through these kinds of camps.
You've got a very good point.
Yeah.
Well that's the,
that's the dirty secret,
you know,
that's sort of being slowly but
surely revealed for the longest time.
There's certain things
that you couldn't test for,
like growth hormone.
You couldn't even find it.
You know,
I had a conversation with jail
son and after he got popped and,
uh,
you know,
he wanted to talk to me on the phone
about like how we should approach it.
And um,
Chels a funny guy,
man,
he's fucking hilarious.
He's a great shit talker too.
But,
uh,
he goes,
yeah,
you know,
those drug tests turns
out they're really good,
got caught for all sorts of shit that
he never thought he'd get caught for
growth hormone EPO.
Aw,
yeah.
He had a cocktail going,
but you know,
in his mind,
I think he had a very small window to
achieve something and he probably was
correct in assuming that he
wasn't the only one doing it.
Yeah.
You just probably correct in
assuming that it's almost impossible,
almost impossible,
but it's really hard
to get to win the belt,
uh,
without it.
Well,
Josie Aldo had a really
interesting thing to say.
Um,
and Andre Panera's as well.
They were talking about,
um,
steroids and they were like,
well,
we support testing,
but I hope the UFC realizes the
fights won't be as exciting.
Like if fighters won't be as good,
well,
they're also going to be out of fights
more often know they're awesome not to be
able to make it,
to fight it.
They're not going to have the healing.
Uh,
yeah.
You know your wife at
all that testosterone.
Yeah.
You're red lining your body
going through camp and they bang,
Bang,
things fucking break off and
selling example think they can work.
That's hard as they're
working without some help.
Some can,
some Canada summer clean,
some have always been clean.
Guys like Frankie Edgar,
these finger clean turn out not to be,
you know,
that's a problem.
I think fake Edgar's
almost certainly clean,
but who knows if he's not
eating EPL and that's,
you know,
one of the secrets to
his incredible cardio.
I don't think that at all.
But you wouldn't know it was my point.
Well,
yeah,
I don't know.
I mean John Fitch Really surprised
me when he turned positive.
Tons of people are surprised.
The Anderson Silva.
It was surprising.
Right.
I wish I could tell you that.
I'll tell you off the air.
Yeah.
I can't tell you on the air
the Anderson Silva situation,
but it's a bit more complicated.
Okay.
First of all,
he unquestionably took some for his,
uh,
leg to try to heal his leg.
38 years old.
He had a broken leg in that position.
There's a lot.
And there's also,
I think that there is,
nothing is my opinion.
I think that it is,
not only is there nothing wrong,
but there may be a case for doctors
to prescribe some sort of steroids,
some controlled amount of,
some sort of steroids for catastrophic
injuries like massive leg breaks or you
know,
Peck terrors or there's some pretty
fucking significant injuries.
Here's another one.
Um,
Hector Lombard went
through a bulging disc,
like a sick,
significantly injured disc
and then was fighting,
you know,
like I think he had a fight
scheduled like six months later.
Good luck trying to recover from
something like that in six months.
I mean you kind of can,
but can you recover enough in three
months to go through a three month ramp?
Most likely not.
And then he turned up positive for some
designer steroid that most people didn't
think they were testing for.
You know,
like the whole Barry bonds thing
with the clear and all this,
you know,
this,
there was a lot of that going on.
I think inboxing,
There's tons of it.
I mean the big giveaway.
So if all these old guys,
these guys in their forties
still competing as cage fighters,
well that doesn't really exist anymore.
I mean it was,
Randy was like kind of the last one
that competed at a super high level,
just able to do it at all.
And that sport,
you're for Nannies,
also an undeniable freak of nature because
Randy never got hurt and mean Randy
lost and he got knocked
out and stuff like that.
But I mean in training,
like he never had a surgery,
never had a broken hand.
You got his arm broken in the Gonzaga Phi,
but that was blocking
a kick.
He looked awfully good for
50 it's a fucking stud.
He's a God damn.
I mean that's key.
That's the real captain America,
Randy couture's a fucking stud.
You have to be to be able to,
don't you assume that he was
on something in that era?
Yes and no.
I don't have the evidence.
I don't want to.
I assume that it's very likely.
Well,
I've,
I've said the same thing about fate or,
and people got mad at me faint
or fought in a dirty league.
He fought in pride.
It was a dirty league.
I mean ensign anyway,
sat in a very safe seat.
You're sitting in and it was laughing
about his contract for pride where they
told him that we don't test for steroids.
Does that mean that that
fade or was not on it?
No,
it doesn't mean that.
But when you have a league
where everyone's on it,
like Vander lay was without a doubt.
And I said one of my favorite
fighters of all time.
It's not my number one favorite.
Yeah.
Like when I get excited to watch a fight,
when Vandelay was fighting,
it was probably the most
excited you you can get.
You know?
It's just like you knew it
was just going to be chaos,
just such a marker,
you know,
he was terrifying,
but he was obviously
on some shit obviously.
And the vendor laid that,
showed up with the UFC
was not the same guy.
He just wasn't me.
Still had that warrior's heart.
But his body just did not
cooperate the same way.
And a lot of is probably because his
endocrine system is all fucked up from
years of using stuff.
So you know,
Waze,
I don't know.
Fuck,
You know,
it's,
I'm just guessing.
I'm just totally guessing.
The Vandelay one Vandelay ran away from
a drug test too and now a suspended
indefinitely,
which I think is kind of fucked up.
You know?
I think if they should have,
they should have the
worst they could give you.
At the time she tested positive.
It was like a year.
They should have given him a year.
They should have said,
look dude,
we know what the fuck is going on.
And then if that's the case,
he'd already be fighting again by now.
Yeah,
you could treat it just
like that's a concession.
I can see that I'm using,
if I run,
if I run a concede.
Yeah.
They wanted to make an example
out of him and they said,
you know,
we're going to give you a lifetime ban.
Well that's fucked up,
man,
because this guy,
this is his life is,
is,
is living.
You essentially took away his
living from one violation,
the only violation of his
entire professional career.
We know,
suspicions aside,
and there's certainly suspicions of
when he was competing in pride and even
possibly suspicions of when
he's competing in the UFC.
But the reality is the guy never got
caught except for the one time where he
evaded it,
test,
treat it like it's a positive test.
You know?
I mean,
I get the whole idea of
sending a fucking message,
but that message is long been set.
I mean everybody knows you if you test
positive and then you see the new testing
rules that they pulled out,
their new ones are brutal.
The new ones are three years,
three years.
Some of them are lifestyle.
It's lifetime.
If you have a second,
um,
uh,
if you try to run away
from a test a second time,
he tried to run away from a
test sell lifetime suspension,
but three years for a first offense,
I don't know if it was three years,
two years,
I think it's two years,
three years for a second offense,
something like that.
Almost a career under not only that,
they take 75% of your purse
up to 75% of your purse.
Yeah,
there's some big ones.
If you take three years
out of a guy's prime,
especially a guy in his late and
late thirties like an Anderson,
like Anderson Anderson's going through,
I don't know what they give him a year
and a half and he's fighting against it.
We'll talk in about 10 minutes and I'll
give you the whole rundown of what I
actually know because you'll,
you'll go,
oh,
I wish I could tell you.
Here it goes.
First offense for testosterone,
antibiotic steroids,
Hgh,
36 month suspension,
find a 50 to 75% second
offense for fucking years.
75 to 100% of fighters purse.
Third Offense,
lifetime suspension,
fine of 100% avoiding
first offense for years,
fine of 75% second offense,
lifetime suspension,
fine of 100% of fighters purse.
Well,
I wonder if that'll be enough.
I guess the idea is
we're going to hang you,
they're trying to set up a sort of almost
a zero tolerance policy in order to
scare guys street.
Well Bron Rhonda Rousey had a very good
point and this point is that if someone
uses some sort of antibiotic steroid
and they can hit their opponent more and
then that opponent dies.
Totally.
This is that is that
murder or manslaughter?
She's very good point.
And you guys are already super heroes.
Exactly.
Need juice them up and yeah,
that's dangerous.
You can,
you can.
Most certainly,
if you're on EPO and human
growth hormone and testosterone,
you can most certainly hit someone more
than you would be able to if you are not
on that.
Especially if like these cases where
guys are testing with like literally
superhuman levels,
like v tour when they,
when they eventually
rescinded the testosterone
replacement therapy thing from
Nevada,
when they tested him,
he was at 1,475 an average man in his
prime is like around 500 to like 800 for
some crazy stud.
So he was like essentially
like double a human being.
Wow.
The level of testosterone.
So it's crazy.
Yeah.
Nevada judge overturns
Vandelia Silva's lifetime ban.
Really?
This just happened today.
Holy Shit.
Breaking News,
Ladies and gentlemen.
Talk about fucking current
and talk about poignant Bob.
Pull that down.
Let's fucking scroll that.
Good for him.
Broke it.
Two 30 Vandelay Silva won a major victory
in court today with a Nevada district
judge throwing out the lifetime ban.
I will applaud.
I applaud that ESPN is Brett Okamoto
reported via Twitter that the judge did
agree that the Nevada state afflict the
plot of state athletic commission had
jurisdiction over silver despite being
an unlicensed athlete at the time,
but that there was not sufficient
evidence to support a lifetime ban.
I agree.
35 12 and one MMA five and seven in the
UFC was handed a hefty punishment after
he ran from random drug tests.
But pepper prepare.
So they,
this is so they overturn the the
lifetime ban,
but it doesn't mean that
he's been reinstated.
Not reinstated.
But what's good.
Oh,
is he still under contract with the UFC?
Like the USC wouldn't even let him.
He said he made a bunch of like
really critical videos about the UFC,
which again,
a lot of these guys,
man,
they need someone to talk to.
I would love to be the guy,
you know,
I'd love to be the guy that
talked to a lot of these guys.
Just go,
don't do that.
Don't do that.
He was a banned for life while
also he was talking about the UFC,
treating people like
slaves and then you know,
Dana was like,
um,
we gave you $9 million.
Wow.
That's how much he made in the USA.
Yes.
It's like,
come on son.
That's not slavery.
That's not slightly,
we fought for seven years.
You mean 9 million bucks
and it's good money.
It's good money,
man.
For every end.
You had seminars,
you ran a gym like you did well,
you're a fucking an Isa loved guy.
I just have a soft spot in my heart
for Vandelay like as a human being.
Like when I know him,
when I,
when I meet him and see him,
I always like to see him.
He's a very warm,
friendly guy and I just,
any guy who was willing
to fight like that guy,
that guy fucking a sweet
guy out of the cage.
That's really,
that's what's so fascinating
about people that I can,
I'm like,
I have,
I had some friends from my gym
who trained with Vandelay Jam.
They all love him.
Oh,
he's a sweet guy.
He's a nice guy.
But he spars like it's life or death.
Like there's videos of him sparring.
I've heard about this.
I'm like,
Jeez,
that was the real stone age.
Or was that shoe box?
Yeah,
shoot the box box.
Well,
who'd Jamar,
uh,
you know,
the guy who ran it,
he should have boxed mean.
Does it mean shoot inbox?
What does it,
what does that mean?
That's a good question.
I mean it's obviously a Portuguese
version probably of shoot box,
which is,
um,
that's how John Danaher
describes MMA shoot boxing,
you know,
shoot box rules,
the rules of engagement and the
way you approach it and think it.
I think that what,
um,
what they did at shoot box was
established like the most aggressive,
most intimidating team ever.
You know,
especially at that time they were
just all berserkers Vander lay show,
gun Ninja,
Anderson pay lay.
There was just one killer after
another in their primes in their prize.
And then you know,
Hofeld Codero guy who's gone from that
gym and now is training like for Breeshia
for doom,
radically increased his striking Hockfield
court Hatfield dos Anjos radically
increased his striking.
So yeah,
it's not just like that
attitude and that drive.
It's also skill.
Like those guys are very skillful
and they just also know about,
they just didn't know about
putting pressure on motherfuckers.
Like they'll sign Angeles versus pedis.
That was just aggression and pressure.
And,
but again,
after that fight,
I've got nick curse on the guy who trained
him and his strength and conditioning
a up,
I think he's here next week
or from her and and uh,
no,
I'm sorry.
He's here on Wednesday.
Um,
and I'm,
I'm really interested to talk
to him about it because his,
um,
his style of training fighters he learned
from the Marinovich has the same guy
that got Bj Penn in the best shape of
his life back when he fought like Diego
Sanchez that Bj,
I think one of the greatest
fighters of all time.
For sure Bj Penn.
But I think that Bj's the prime BJ.
Yeah.
You know,
so I'm,
I'm really curious to see what their
approach was to get a guy in the kind of
condition where he could fight five
retarded hard rounds like that.
So I don't know how it's possible.
I don't know how it's possible
in the amateur divisions.
We did two minute rounds
and if you were in a,
you know,
it really intense rounds we striking was
heavy and you're mixing the grappling
with it.
All the heavy exertion of grappling.
I was more,
you talked about having a heart attack,
doing hot yoga.
I felt that way all the time.
Like I'm going to die.
And I watch these guys on TV doing five
minute rounds after five minute rounds
and sometimes walking back to their
corners have this crazy round with their
mouths closed,
breathing calmly through their noses.
To me,
that's the most freakish
thing about these athletes.
Did you watch Neil Magni this weekend?
Well,
I know,
I actually,
I actually listened to
the fight companion.
Oh dude,
it was Neil magnes got
insane fucking cardio.
It's insane.
Well,
one of them do.
Benson Henderson Henderson
has these frenetic finds,
tons of grappling,
tons of striking.
He has never tired.
They don't know what it's like
to be tired of these work ethic.
Just insane work ethic and never getting
out of shape and never abusing your
body and always eating the right foods,
getting the right rest,
putting altitude tents up in your house
is Neil actually trains at altitude.
He trains as in Denver,
in altitude MMA.
Actually that's his gym in Denver.
But yeah,
that's,
there's an advantage in that for sure.
It's an advantage.
And a sleeping at altitude is the big one.
They actually say that you should like
go up to big bear to sleep and come down
to like c level to train.
That's what they say.
Oh yeah,
I see that.
Cause that way you could put
out more output glowed and yeah,
more work.
But you recover because of the,
uh,
sleeping and altitude.
Right.
Um,
we're almost out of time.
But what did you,
what's the,
what's the biggest thing that you
got out of this whole experiment?
Other than a great book,
which I've heard nothing but
fantastic things about this book.
By the way.
It's one of the reasons why
I wanted to get you in here.
I've heard that you are
incredibly honest in this,
about your fears and though the
experience and very eloquent.
So the professor in the
cage go get this book.
You fucks.
That's great.
Um,
I can't wait to read it.
Well thanks.
I don't even read hardcover books anymore.
Well,
like I said,
you know,
I,
when I was writing it,
I was thinking to myself,
uh,
sometimes like,
you know,
Joe Rogan doesn't like this book.
It means because it means I totally
whiffed I'm going to kindle it too.
I don't read.
Kindles are so much better to manage.
Well,
the little thing,
and I liked the paper
making your own it.
Um,
what did you,
what is the big thing that you got
out of this personally or sort of an
intellectual above?
Uh,
I mean intellectually is personally,
right?
Personally,
you know,
there was,
I had been through a
sort of lifetime of a,
I don't know,
like I was a late bloomer.
I was a kid,
um,
real small,
always sort of the runt of my,
uh,
in school came to me in my ailments,
sort of an average size guy now,
but I came to my growth really late.
And so I sort of have a basic,
you know,
school boy's story about getting
pushed around and bullied and,
and it's,
and there's no heroism in that story.
Uh,
and I always backed down.
I always ran for it.
I always found some way out of it.
It wasn't because I was a pacifist,
it wasn't like it had some noble high
minded reasons for avoiding the violence.
It was that I was scared and I
knew I was gonna get my ass kicked.
But I've always kind of felt like
that's no excuse for not for fighting.
You know,
that there's a,
you should stand up to the bullet.
Um,
I've always felt that way and
even though I never did it so,
so,
so part of what I wanted to
do was I wanted to go into
that cage and I wanted to
sort of stand up to guys who were stronger
than me and more skilled than me and
sort of taking those beatings that I felt
like I should have taken 20 years ago.
You know what I mean?
Um,
and so as deep well,
yeah.
You know,
this is,
I don't know if you've ever
had experiences like that as a,
as a boy.
Um,
where are you,
where you behaved in a fashion
that you define as cowardly?
Yes,
definitely.
And it's amazing to me.
I'm 42 years old now.
Um,
I've had a lot of
accomplishments in my life.
I have a beautiful wife,
I have little children who are wonderful.
Um,
it's amazing to me how much psychological
weight that still carries from me that
I could still make myself blush,
uh,
thinking back to those moments.
And so part of it was a redemption
story from me about whether I could,
whether I could do
something to redeem myself,
at least in my own eyes for those
times when I'd flinched a as a kid.
That's awesome.
I love that.
I love that you did that.
I don't love that you
still blushing over it.
It's silly.
So stupid.
It's so crazy.
But it just means you've got work to do.
That's all it is.
You know,
just kind of worked before you
realize you're not that guy anymore.
Right.
You know?
I sort of became what I was terrified of.
That's to avoid,
you know,
being bullied.
I just became someone who was,
I never got in fights like high school on.
I never got in fights,
but I didn't get in fights by becoming
far stronger than I ever was before.
But I still would think back to like
guys that I was scared of when I was in
high school.
Like,
whoa.
But it never,
I never feel like I want to go back
now and look and kicked her ass.
Like that was surprising to me
that I never wanted to do that.
Yeah.
And I never wanted to go back.
Like,
hey dude,
you remember when you fucked with me.
I never,
I never wanted to do that.
I always,
I was,
but I also never carried
that burden around.
Yeah.
One time when I was,
um,
I think it was about like 19 or 20 when
I was already a black belt and I was
working out at my gym where I used to
teach and in Boston and I was just doing
these heavy rounds on the bag,
preparing for this tournament.
I had looked up and this guy was watching
that used to bully me in junior high
school,
this guy,
any from my high school from June,
I'm just like really rough junior
high school in Jamaica plain,
which is,
it's kind of gentrified now,
but at the time was like a really sketchy
area of Massachusetts and I looked up
and I felt bad for the guy.
It was really like,
instead of being angry at him,
I felt bad for him.
No,
that's right.
I mean,
all those guys from high
school were just kids too.
You know,
they were fuck ups too.
They had their own insecurities.
They had their own problems.
People,
it's stupid to be hung up on it.
Um,
and I'm not very hung up on it.
I don't have any fantasies of going
back and beating those guys up.
But I do hope they'll read
the book and they'll think,
boy,
he was a character for the boy,
but he,
but he grew into a brave
man professor in the cage.
You could buy it right now.
And it's available on Amazon.
Right?
I can get a candle.
Oh yeah.
All right.
Beautiful.
Thank you John.
Really appreciate it.
I appreciate it.
Let's just come on.
I appreciate it,
man.
Go,
go buy it.
Go read it.
Ladies and gentlemen,
the professor in the cage.
I'll be reading it.
I'll be talking about
it on a future podcast,
I'm sure.
Thank you,
sir.
Appreciate it.
Extra.
Yeah.